I'm Jenna Fisher and I'm Angela Kinsey. We were on The Office together and we're best friends. And now we're doing the Ultimate Office rewatch podcast just for you. Each week we will break down an episode of The Office and give exclusive behind-the-scenes stories that only two people who were there can tell you. We're The Office, ladies. Hello everyone. Good morning, our afternoon, our night time.
我是珍娜·菲舍尔，我是安吉拉·金斯利。我们曾一起出演过《办公室》，并且是最好的朋友。现在我们专门为你制作了终极《办公室》重温播客。每周我们都会剖析一集《办公室》，并分享只有当事两人才能告诉你的独家幕后故事。女士们，我们就是《办公室》。大家好。早上好，下午好，或者晚上好。
I like our intro. This is our new intro. Today we are here to talk about Mafia, season six, episode six. And Angie and I were kind of texting back and forth about some fun, what would you call them, asides, mini deep dives that we went on as a result of this episode. And you have one that I was like, don't tell me anymore. Don't tell me anymore. I want to hear it on the podcast.
我喜欢我们的片头。这是我们的新片头。今天我们在这里聊聊第六季第六集《黑手党》。安吉和我在短信里反复讨论了一些有趣的内容，你管它们叫什么来着，就是我们因这一集而展开的副线剧情、微深度探秘。你有一个观点让我觉得：别再跟我说了。别再跟我说了。我想在播客里听。
I can't wait. I have one that I just dipped my toe in, you guys. There's so much more to it. I actually bought a book. What? Your own deep dive led you to now buy a book? Yeah, exactly. That's what happened with Clementine Paddleford.
我迫不及待了。伙计们，我有一个只是浅尝辄止的话题。里面还有更多内容呢。我其实买了一本书。什么？你自己的深度探秘让你现在去买了一本书？对，没错。克莱门蒂娜·帕德福德就是这样的。
I have her book. We became obsessed. I know. Oh my. How about you hit us with a submarine? We'll get into it. Well, I'm going to tell you that this was written by Brent Forrester and directed by Dave Rogers. And my summary is this.
我有她的书。我们当时着迷得不行。我懂。哦，天哪。要不你给我们来个潜水艇式的开场？我们深入聊聊。好吧，我要告诉大家的是，这一集由布伦特·福雷斯特编剧，戴夫·罗杰斯执导。我的总结是这样的。
Michael is visited by an insurance salesman, whom Dwight and Andy convinced him is a member of the Italian mafia. Michael then feels pressured to purchase a very expensive insurance package that he does not need. Meanwhile, Kevin takes over Jim's office because Jim and Pam are on their honeymoon. In Puerto Rico? Yes. But everyone keeps calling them.
迈克尔接待了一位保险推销员，德怀特和安迪说服迈克尔相信此人是意大利黑手党成员。于是迈克尔感到压力山大，被迫购买了一份他根本不需要的昂贵保险套餐。与此同时，凯文占用了吉姆的办公室，因为吉姆和帕姆去度蜜月了。去波多黎各？是的。但每个人都不停地打电话给他们。
We'll get to it. Yes, they do. And Kevin accidentally cancels their credit cards. Amazing. All right. Fastback number one. I reached out to Brent Forrester. We always love to hear from Brent.
我们一会儿就聊到这。是的，确实如此。而且凯文不小心取消了他们的信用卡。太棒了。好了。花絮第一条。我联系了布伦特·福雷斯特。我们总是很喜欢听到布伦特的消息。
Oh, Brent is so fun. Like I said, he wrote this episode and he was very interested in discussing the tone of this episode, which he pointed out is a little different. Here's what he had to say. I wrote the office episode called Mafia, considered now a minor comedy classic, but it was controversial at the time of shooting. Why? Because what makes the office great is this tone of naturalism, realism, groundedness.
哦，布伦特太有趣了。就像我说的，他编写了这一集，他非常想讨论这一集的基调，他指出这集基调有点不同。他是这么说的。我写了《办公室》里名为《黑手党》的一集，现在被认为是一部小型喜剧经典，但在拍摄时却颇具争议。为什么？因为《办公室》伟大的之处在于这种自然主义、现实主义、脚踏实地的基调。
And this episode pushed in the opposite direction tonally. The whole premise is farcical. Michael Scott believes an Italian-American insurance agent is a mafioso, that's farce. When we added Ed Helms dressed as a mechanic in order to justify bringing a ranch into a restaurant, things got tense on set between the guys behind the camera, the director Dave Rogers and me, and the guys in front of the camera, Steve Carell, Rainn Wilson, and Ed Helms, who had to play this material as real, very, very challenging. So I remember this tension.
而这一集在基调上往相反的方向推了。整个前提是闹剧式的。迈克尔·斯科特相信一个意大利裔美国保险经纪人是黑手党成员，这就是闹剧。当我们让埃德·海尔姆斯打扮成机修工，以此来合理解释把一辆牧场车开进餐馆时，镜头后面的男人们——导演戴夫·罗杰斯和我，以及镜头前面的男人们——史蒂夫·卡瑞尔、雷恩·威尔逊和埃德·海尔姆斯（他们必须把这些桥段演得很真实）之间的气氛变得紧张起来，这真的非常有挑战性。所以我记得这种紧张感。
The guys in general did not love when we pushed into farce. There was always a lot of pushback from all of us in the cast. We just loved that early season realism more than anything. Well, you know, Jenna, I know some of the bigger storylines, and particularly with Dwight, would crack us up, right? Like we could get on board with some of the big storylines. But when the whole entire storyline was so absurd, that's when it was harder, I think, for us because we needed the balance of like the smaller, like just like run-of-the-mill,
总的来说，当剧情推向闹剧时，大家并不是很喜欢。我们演员中所有人总是会有很多抵触情绪。比起其他任何东西，我们就是更喜欢早期剧集的现实主义。好吧，你知道的，珍娜，我知道一些较大的故事线，特别是关于德怀特的，会让我们捧腹大笑，对吧？比如我们可以接受一些大的故事线。但当整个故事线都如此荒诞时，我觉得对我们来说就更难了，因为我们需要平衡，比如那种较小规模的、司空见惯的、
daily work life mixed in with something crazy. But this was kind of just crazy start to finish. It's funny because in this rewatch, I have loved these farcical storylines. I mean, remember when those guys all put on fake mustaches and they went to Utica to steal the industrial copy? Yes, I was cracking up. I mean, I also feel like if you go all the way back to the injury and Michael grilling his foot on a George Foreman grill, I mean, that's, I don't know if that's necessarily
日常工作生活与疯狂事情的混合。但这几乎是从头到尾都很疯狂。说来有趣，在这个重温过程中，我一直很喜欢这些闹剧式的故事线。我是说，还记得那些家伙都戴上假胡子去尤蒂卡偷工业复印机的时候吗？是的，我当时笑得前仰后合。我的意思是，我也觉得如果你一直追溯到受伤事件以及迈克尔在乔治·福尔曼烤架上烤脚，我的意思是，那是，我不知道这是否一定是
farce, but that's definitely very broad. Yeah. I just think the difference for this one is it was the whole entire storyline, oh, your cat is here. Hi, sunny cat. The sunny is just, wait, I wish I could take a picture of this. This is so cute. Jenna's cat is like the whole screen.
闹剧，但绝对是非常夸张的。是的。我只是觉得这一集的区别在于它是整个故事线，哦，你的猫在这儿。嗨，阳光猫。这只阳光猫简直是，等等，我真希望我能拍张照片。这太可爱了。珍娜的猫简直占据了整个屏幕。
How are you? It's just on the microphone. He's just come for a visit. Oh, it is so funny is I just saw his tail go through your plant around the corner and then there he was. I know. So cute. This is our life right now, you guys, with like the minimum occupancy in studio is I'm
你好吗？它就在麦克风上。它只是来串个门。哦，太搞笑了，我刚才看到它的尾巴穿过了转角处的植物，然后它就出现在那儿了。我懂。太可爱了。伙计们，这就是我们现在的日常生活，演播室里的最低人数就是我
here and Jenna's in her closet. With my cat. With her cat. He sits in my office most of the day with me, so he wanted to say hi. But yeah, I mean, you're right. It was more of a side storyline, but the injury was like that was, you know, he's asking Pam to rub butter on his foot. I don't know.
在这儿，珍娜在她的衣帽间里。和我的猫一起。和她的猫一起。它大部分时间陪着我在办公室里，所以它想打个招呼。不过说真的，你是对的。这更像是一个副线剧情，但受伤事件就像是，你知道的，他让帕姆把黄油抹在他脚上。我不知道。
I have to say in the rewatch, I love these storylines. And by the way, I'm also noticing that it's coming on the heels of what Jen Salada was saying last week about how her storyline in the promotion was so dramatic. And it really goes to show like how much influence an individual writer and their script can have on the tone of an episode. Oh, 100%. And also the characters they write for. Yes.
我得说在重温时，我非常喜欢这些故事线。顺便说一句，我也注意到这紧接着詹·萨拉达上周所说的话，即她在晋升中的故事线是多么戏剧性。这确实表明了一个单独的编剧及其剧本对一集节目的基调能有多大影响。哦，百分之百。还有他们为之写剧本的角色。是的。
All right. Well, speaking of storylines, my fast fact number two is all about a deleted storyline in this episode, which by the way, this deleted storyline would still show up in the episode description on Netflix. It's still there on iTunes as well. You're kidding because it's not in it at all. Not in it at all. I was surprised, Jenna, when I watched the deleted scenes, it's the whole entire runner
好吧，说到故事线，我的花絮第二号是关于这一集里一个被删掉的故事线，顺便说一句，这个被删掉的故事线居然仍然会出现在网飞的剧集简介里。它在iTunes上也还在。你在开玩笑吗？因为它根本不在正片里。根本不在正片里。珍娜，当我看到被删掉的片段时我很惊讶，这整段都是删掉的片段
of the deleted scenes. It was a big storyline. Let me tell you what it is because, oh, I had a reaction. Yeah, you did. Sure. Erin was supposed to be cleaning Pam's watercolor. Her famous watercolor that Michael bought from her art show, she sprays the glass with this cleaner and then Creed kind of distracts her by chatting her up and the spray seeps
的主线。这是一个很大的故事线。让我告诉你它是什么，因为，哦，我有反应了。对，你确实有。当然。艾琳本该清理帕姆的水彩画。那是迈克尔从她的艺术展上买的她著名的水彩画，她用这种清洁剂喷洒玻璃，然后克里德通过跟她聊天来分散她的注意力，清洁剂就渗入了
under the glass and the watercolor is ruined. Yeah. Erin destroys Pam's watercolor while she's on her honeymoon was the storyline. If you watch the deleted scenes, you watch it melt like all the colors like slide down to the bottom of the frame. I literally went, I forgot it was in the story at one point. And then there's another deleted scene where she asked Kelly to help her fix it. And Kelly's like, oh yeah, I can do watercolor.
玻璃下方，水彩画就毁了。是的，故事线就是艾琳在帕姆度蜜月时毁掉了帕姆的水彩画。如果你看了被删掉的片段，你会看到它融化，所有的颜色都像那样滑到画框底部。我当时简直说，我一度忘了它在剧情里。然后还有另一个被删掉的片段，她让凯利帮她修复。凯利说，哦，对，我会画水彩画。
But what Kelly does is she like adds a rainbow and a sunshine, but the painting is still totally melty. And then in the end, Erin calls Pam on her honeymoon and says she ruined it. And Pam has this line where she says, you know what, I will be mad at you about ruining my painting when I get back. Stop calling me. Tell people to stop calling us. There was a scene that led up before she ruined your painting.
但凯利做的是她加了一道彩虹和阳光，然而画作仍然完全融化了。然后最后，艾琳在帕姆度蜜月时打电话给她，说她把画毁了。帕姆有一句台词是这样说的：你知道吗，等我回去后，我再为毁画的事跟你生气。别再打电话了。告诉别人别再给我们打电话了。在毁画之前其实还有一段铺垫的场景。
I'm going to save it. I'm going to share it when it would have happened in the episode, okay? Okay. That sort of set up why she even started cleaning it in the first place. Oh, okay. Yeah. But I think it will make more sense if I bring it up where it would have occurred. I like it.
我要留着它。等它原本应该在剧中出现的时候，我再分享出来，好吗？好的。那段大致铺垫了她为什么一开始要擦拭画作。哦，好吧。对。但我觉得如果我在它原本发生的地方提出来，会更有意义。我喜欢。
After we read the script in our table read, which is the week before we're meant to shoot it, I like as soon as I started reading it, I got hot inside, you know, like you heat up and I could barely focus on the rest of the table read. You had a physical reaction. I did. You like flushed like your cheeks were red. Yes. I waited till after the table read, everybody left and this was unusual.
在我们剧本围读之后——也就是我们打算拍摄的前一周——就像我开始读的时候一样，我心里就开始发热，你知道的，就像你开始发热一样，我几乎无法集中精力进行接下来的围读。你有生理反应。我确实有。你脸红了，双颊通红。是的。我等到围读结束、大家都离开之后——这很不寻常。
I did not normally stay after a table read and like give my feelings. No, no. In fact, we usually had to scooch out because we had to go to hair and makeup to get back to set. Yeah. To go back to shoot. But I was like, listen, you cannot destroy Pam's painting. You can't do it.
我通常不会在围读结束后留下来发表我的感受。不，不。事实上，我们通常得赶紧溜走，因为我们得去化妆间弄头发和化妆，好赶回片场。对。回去拍戏。但我当时说：听着，你不能毁掉帕姆的画。你不能这么做。
It's the heartbeat of the show. It's on the wall. It's her relationship with Michael. It's, it's hope. It's so many things like you don't understand. Like you can't make this a gag. And Paul Lieberstein was like, I think it's funny. What are you talking about?
这是节目的心跳。它挂在墙上。它是她和迈克尔的关系。它是，它是希望。它是很多东西，你根本不明白。你不能把这当成一个恶作剧。保罗·利伯斯坦就说：我觉得这挺好笑的。你在说什么呢？
And it was a battle. I was like, no, no, no, I don't, you, you don't understand. Like you cannot do it. And I called Greg, I would like made my case to anyone who would listen. They shot it anyway. They were like, I'm sorry. It's staying in. We really like this gag.
这是一场战斗。我说：不，不，不，我不，你，你不明白。你不能这么做。我给格雷格打了电话，我向任何愿意听的人陈述了我的理由。他们还是拍了。他们说：我很抱歉。它会保留。我们真的很喜欢这个恶作剧。
We think it's great. Oh, they were so wrong. They were so wrong. Lady, after we shot it. I went into the edit bay and I was like, you have to take this out. You have to take this out. I appealed to Dave Rogers. I appealed to Brent Forrester.
我们觉得太棒了。哦，他们大错特错了。他们大错特错了。女士们，拍完之后。我走进剪辑室说：你们必须把它删掉。你们必须把它删掉。我向戴夫·罗杰斯申诉。我向布伦特·福雷斯特申诉。
Like I would not shut up about it. Finally, in the end, they took it out. They took it out and I was so relieved. But you'll see next week, there's not Pam's watercolor on the wall because that was the week they were editing and still deciding. So if you look, Pam's watercolor is missing for a couple of episodes and we just sneakily put it back on the wall without saying anything. Oh my gosh.
我就像祥林嫂一样说个不停。最后，他们把它删了。他们把它删了，我松了一口气。但你会发现下周的墙上没有帕姆的水彩画，因为那是他们正在剪辑并仍在做决定的那一周。所以如果你仔细看，帕姆的水彩画在好几集里都不见了，然后我们悄悄把它挂回墙上，什么也没说。哦天哪。
So for those episodes, there's no painting because you were still pleading your case. Yes, but I would not give up. And then I mean, listen, the whole series ends on Pam's watercolor. I know. And I couldn't imagine it ending any other way. I mean, that made me ball my eyes out. I know. And you better believe that I marched right up to Paul Lieberstein when I read that ending
所以在那些剧集里，没有这幅画，因为你还在据理力争？是的，但我绝不放弃。然后我的意思是，听着，整个系列以帕姆的水彩画收尾。我知道。我无法想象它以任何其他方式结束。我的意思是，这让我哭得死去活来。我知道。而且你最好相信，当我读到大结局的那个结尾时，我直接走到保罗·利伯斯坦面前，对他说：保罗，你现在明白为什么艾琳不能毁掉水彩画了吧？你明白了吗？你把这事记在心里好几年。
of the finale and I was like, Paul, do you see now why Erin couldn't destroy the watercolor? Do you see? You held on to that for years. Yes. Well, I'm so glad you did because it represents such a tender moment between Michael and Pam and it is the hope. It's hope. It's hope in a frame.
是的。好吧，我很高兴你这么做了，因为它代表了迈克尔和帕姆之间如此温柔的时刻，它就是希望。它是希望。它是画框里的希望。
It's hope in a frame. I wish I had said that. It's hope in a frame. You're welcome. Oh man. Well, I'm really glad you fought hard for it. I knew you didn't want it to be destroyed. I remembered all of that.
画框里的希望。我真希望这话是我说的。画框里的希望。不客气。哦天哪。好吧，我真的很高兴你为它据理力争。我知道你不希望它被毁掉。我记得这一切。
I did not remember how hard you had to fight for it. Yeah. I mean, there were two things in the series that I fought hard for. I would consistently fight that there'd be no infidelity in Jim and Pam's relationship. That would often get brought up and John and I would go say, no, no, no, no, no, no. And this was the other thing. Don't destroy the painting. Yeah.
我不记得你为之奋斗得有多艰难了。对。我的意思是，这个系列中有两件事是我极力争取的。我会一直争取吉姆和帕姆的关系中绝对不能出现不忠。这经常被提出来，约翰和我就会说，不，不，不，不，不，不。这就是另一件事。别毁了那幅画。对。
Well, Jenna, the amazing Randy Cordray shared with us that the whole destroying of Pam's painting was considered a mini stunt. Oh. Here's how they had to do it. Our special effects coordinator, Mike Thompson, created what the special effects folks call an AB reaction. It's where two different substances are inert and non-reactive until mixed together. Oh, I remember that from chemistry class.
好吧，珍娜，了不起的兰迪·科德雷跟我们分享说，毁掉帕姆水彩画的整个过程被认为是一个微型特技。哦。以下是他们不得不这样做的原因。我们的特效统筹迈克·汤普森创造了特效人员所称的AB反应。这是一种情况：两种不同的物质在混合之前是惰性的、不发生反应的。哦，我从化学课上记得这个。
I was going to say you didn't know we're going to have a little bit of science today. The A substance was pre-applied over the watercolor. It dried clear and was not visible. The B substance, a reactive, also clear liquid, was what Aaron sprayed. There were minute openings in the top of the frame to allow the B liquid to run inside the glass. And when the B chemical reacted with the A, it changed the colors and achieved the desired result of the gag, which was the watercolors melting.
我正要说呢，你不知道我们今天会有一点科学知识吧。A物质预先涂在水彩画上。它干后是透明的，看不见。B物质是一种反应性的、同样透明的液体，就是艾琳喷洒的那种。画框顶部有微小的开口，可以让B液体流进玻璃内部。当B化学物质与A发生反应时，它改变了颜色，达到了恶作剧的预期效果，也就是水彩画融化。
He even sent us a video of their practice run, which we can put in stories. Oh, then so people can see the melting of the watercolor. Yes. Wow. But I thought that was so interesting. Look what all they had to do to make this moment happen. I mean, ultimately, I'm glad it didn't make it in the show, right? Yeah.
他甚至给我们发了一段他们排练的视频，我们可以把它发到快拍里。哦，这样大家就能看到水彩画融化了。是的。哇。但我觉得这太有趣了。看看他们为了实现这个时刻付出了多少努力。我的意思是，最终，我很高兴它没有出现在节目中，对吧？是的。
But pretty cool to see what all they had to do. Gosh, it's sort of like a very mini version of everything Randy was doing to get a horse to go over Niagara Falls. Oh, no. I know. Like, how do I make this happen? And then, oh, we actually cut it out of the episode. Right.
但能看到他们为了这个做了多少事真是太酷了。天哪，这有点像是兰迪为了让马跨过尼亚加拉大瀑布所做一切的超微缩版。哦，不。我知道。比如，我怎么才能让这发生？然后，哦，我们实际上把它从剧集里剪掉了。对。
All right. Well, fast fact number three. We have a very big guest star this week, Mike Starr as Angelo Grotti. You guys might remember him from Dumb and Dumber. He had a scene stealing role. Oh, yeah. He has been on Chicago Fire, The Young and the Restless, Ed. He was so great.
好吧，花絮第三号。本周我们有一位非常大的客串明星，迈克·斯塔尔饰演安杰洛·格罗蒂。大家可能在《阿呆与阿瓜》中记得他。他扮演了一个抢尽风头的角色。哦，对。他出演过《芝加哥烈焰》、《年轻和骚动不安的一族》、《艾德》。他太棒人了。
He was the nicest man. So nice. He's just been in everything, you guys. Everything. He's a total pro. I found this interview he did, and it was so cool. He grew up in Queens in Flushing, right near Shea Stadium, which is by where the Mets play. But in the interview, he said he was a Giants fan.
他是最亲切的人。太友善了。伙计们，他简直演过所有作品。所有作品。他是个十足的专业演员。我找到了他做的一个采访，太酷了。他在皇后区法拉盛长大的，就在谢亚体育场附近，也就是大都会队主场旁边。但在采访中他说他是巨人队的球迷。
He's married and has two kids. His wife is a surgeon, and he kept his family in New York, and he would travel to be an actor. He got bit by the acting bug and created this life as a working actor, but also raising his family on the East Coast, and he said he just goes where the work takes him. And I don't know. It just sounded so cool. Again, another example of how lucky we were as a show to get these amazing, amazing actors.
他已婚，有两个孩子。他的妻子是一名外科医生，他把家人留在纽约，然后通过旅行来当演员。他迷上了表演，作为一名高产演员创造了这种生活，同时也在东海岸抚养他的家庭，他说他只是哪里有工作就去哪里。我不知道。听起来太酷了。再次证明了作为一部剧集，我们能请到这些极其出色的演员是多么幸运。
Well, that's all I got, lady. Well, I have something from my Kinsey Digital Clutter. Oh, these are my favorite segments. I'm telling you, I think I need a sting that's like, Angela's Digital Clutter. Oh, my kids, because I have so much. We do need a Digital Clutter sting, I agree. Here's what I got. We filmed this in September of 2009, so I went digging in my Digital Clutter, and I
好吧，女士，这就是我的全部了。好吧，我从我的安吉拉数字杂物堆里找出了点东西。哦，这是我最喜欢的环节。我跟你说，我觉得我需要一个类似于“安吉拉的数字杂物堆”的音效。哦，我的孩子们，因为我有太多东西了。我们确实需要一个数字杂物堆的音效，我同意。这是我找到的。我们在2009年9月拍摄了这一集，所以我翻找了我的数字杂物堆，我
found an email I wrote from set while we were filming this episode. Oh. I sent it to two of my friends, and this is what it said. Hey, guys. So I'm in the background of a bunch of scenes today, so get ready for random emails with ridiculous links. And then I attached a link of, like, animals doing crazy things. OK.
找到了一封我在拍摄这一集时从片场写的电子邮件。哦。我把它发给了我的两个朋友，上面是这样写的：嘿，伙计们。所以今天我在很多场景里都是背景板，准备好接收带有荒谬链接的随机邮件吧。然后我附上了一个链接，比如动物做疯狂事情的链接。好吧。
Right? Animals being silly. One of my friends was at work when she received this, and she responded and said, sorry, Ange, but work is super busy here today. Can you please forward all the funny emails to my personal account instead so I can check them later? Thanks. Oh.
对吧？动物在犯傻。我的一个朋友收到这个邮件时正在上班，她回复说：对不起，安吉，但今天这里工作超级忙。你能把所有有趣的邮件都转发到我的个人账户上，以便我以后查看吗？谢谢。哦。
I was pretending to be at work, but just surfing the internet, blasting one of my friends who was really at work, and she was like, can you, can you stop? Oh, my gosh, that's so funny. That made me laugh. There you go. That's a little something from my Digital Clutter for the week we filmed Mafia. I mean, I feel like this could be a new segment on the podcast. I'd be willing to turn FastFact number three into Angela's Digital Clutter every week.
我当时假装在上班，其实只是在网上冲浪，还轰炸了一个真正正在上班的朋友，而她的反应是：你能，你能停下来吗？哦，天哪，太搞笑了。这把我逗笑了。给你。这就是我为拍摄《黑手党》那一周准备的数字杂物堆里的一点小料。我的意思是，我觉得这可以成为播客的一个新环节。我愿意每周把花絮第三号变成安吉拉的数字杂物堆。
These are wonderful. I don't know if it's always going to come through, but. Well, that's part of the appeal. Will it pay off or won't it? We'll see. We should try. All right. I'm assigning that to you next week.
这些太棒了。我不知道它是不是总能顺利进行，不过。好吧，这就是吸引力的一部分。它会成功还是失败呢？我们走着瞧。我们应该试试。好的。我把这个任务交给你下周做了。
Oh, no. FastFact number three is Angela's Digital Clutter. Okay. Okay. That might be because I already started prepping it and I don't have a FastFact three yet. Oh, I see how it is. All right. Why don't we take a break and then we'll come back and break down this episode.
哦，不。花絮第三号是安吉拉的数字杂物堆。好吧。好吧。那可能是因为我已经开始筹备了，而且我还没有准备好花絮第三号。哦，我懂是怎么回事了。好吧。要不我们休息一下，然后回来剖析这一集。
Awesome. Well, we are back. We're in the conference room because Michael is discussing the fundamentals of business. Yeah. He has written on a dry erase board, handshakes, small talk, shut up and sell. Yeah. He invites people to give suggestions for small talk. He really likes Meredith's idea and he says, come on up here.
太棒了。好吧，我们回来了。我们在会议室里，因为迈克尔正在讨论商业基础知识。是的。他在白板上写着：握手、闲聊、闭嘴并卖出。是的。他邀请大家为闲聊提出建议。他真的很喜欢梅雷迪思的主意，他说：到前面来。
She says the weekend. He's like, that's great. Let's riff on that. Get on up here, Meredith. That's right. They start to role play. Michael's like, so, Meredith, how was your weekend? What did you do?
她说：周末。他觉得：太棒了。我们顺着这个即兴发挥一下。上来吧，梅雷迪思。没错。他们开始角色扮演。迈克尔说：那么，梅雷迪思，你周末过得怎么样？你做了什么？
And Meredith says, well, I caught my son taking a dump on the upper part of the toilet. He calls it an upper decker and Michael's like, oh, God, okay, you know, just go sit down. That made me laugh out loud. It made me laugh too. And I remember when we were filming this, we all cracked up and I went and looked in the shooting draft. That line is not in there.
梅雷迪思说：嗯，我抓到我儿子在马桶上层拉屎。他管这叫上层排泄物，迈克尔说：哦，天哪，好吧，你知道的，去坐下吧。这逗得我哈哈大笑。我也笑了。我记得我们拍这场戏的时候，我们都笑裂了，我去看了一下拍摄剧本。那句台词根本不在里面。
The upper decker line? It's not in the shooting draft. This is what was in the shooting draft. Meredith says, I caught my son doing my fur coat. I had to shave off one of the sleeves. Oh, Michael's like gross. So I texted Kate. I said, Kate, did you improvise the upper decker line?
上层排泄物的台词？它不在拍摄剧本里。拍摄剧本里写的是这样的。梅雷迪思说：我抓到我儿子在穿我的皮大衣。我不得不把其中一个袖子剃掉。哦，迈克尔觉得很恶心。所以我给凯特发了短信。我说：凯特，上层排泄物那句台词是你即兴发挥的吗？
I mean, come on, where did that come from? And she said, no, Paul Lieberstein whispered it in my ear after the very first take. Oh my gosh. That just goes to show you that when Paul Lieberstein was in the background of a scene, he was still writing the show in his head. Right. He was pitching jokes. And the rest of us had no idea what he whispered in her ear.
我的意思是，拜托，那是打哪儿来的？她说：不是，保罗·利伯斯坦在拍完第一条后在我耳边悄悄说的。哦，天哪。这简直表明，当保罗·利伯斯坦在某个场景里充当背景板时，他脑子里依然在为节目编写剧本。没错。他在抛梗。而我们其他人根本不知道他在她耳边悄悄说了什么。
So when she said it, we all heard it for the first time. Oh, brilliant. They would do that to us, you guys. And it would send us all into fits of giggles because we were ready and prepared for the crazy line about the fur coat, right? Right. And all of a sudden, we get hit with the upper decker. I want to point out that at 49 seconds, you'll get a real good shot of the fact that Kate
所以当她说出来的时候，我们所有人都是第一次听到。哦，太绝了。伙计们，他们会这样对我们。这会让我们所有人笑得前仰后合，因为我们已经准备好并预料到了关于皮大衣的疯狂台词，对吧？对。而突然之间，我们被上层排泄物的梗击中了。我想指出的是，在49秒的时候，你会清楚地看到凯特
is wearing that Nanette LePour vest again. This is the third time now. Jenna, I noticed that too. The woman loves that sweater vest. It's a very expensive sweater vest. I'm telling you, I was working with a stylist at the time, and it was like $200 back then. How does Meredith afford this vest? I don't know, but she wears it a lot, so she's getting her money out of it.
又穿着那件南妮·勒普尔背心了。这已经是第三次了。珍娜，我也注意到了。这位女士太喜欢那件毛衣背心了。那是一件很贵的毛衣背心。我跟你说，我当时跟一位造型师合作过，那时候就得200美元左右。梅雷迪思怎么买得起这件背心的？我不知道，但她经常穿，所以她穿回本了。
She is. Well, the role play doesn't work. And Michael's so frustrated. He's like, God, I could fill a book with the stuff you guys don't know about business. And Ryan's like, go write it. Write a book. Yeah. So Michael immediately goes into his office.
她确实穿回本了。好吧，角色扮演没成功。迈克尔沮丧极了。他说：天哪，你们对商业一无所知，我能写厚厚一本书。瑞安说：去写吧。写本书。所以迈克尔立刻走进他的办公室。
He starts dictating his book, The Fundamentals of Business by Michael Scott, One Billion Sold, More Than the Bible. After one, the businessman. And then he stops talking. Yeah. I got curious as happens. I was like, how many copies of the Bible have been sold? I would think a lot.
他开始口述他的书《迈克尔·斯科特商业基础知识》，销量十亿，超过圣经。第一章，商人。然后他不说话了。对。我像往常一样好奇起来。我想：圣经到底卖出了多少本？我想应该有很多吧。
Yeah. Well, I'll tell you what, it's so many that even if Michael's book, The Fundamentals of Business by Michael Scott sold one billion copies, it would not be more than the Bible. The Guinness Book of World Records estimates that more than five billion copies of the Bible have been sold. The Koran has sold approximately 800 million copies. And the Book of Mormon has sold around 120 million copies. They used, I guess, historical records and a variety of other sources to get those numbers.
好吧，我告诉你，数量如此之多，以至于即使迈克尔的书《迈克尔·斯科特商业基础知识》卖出十亿册，也不会超过《圣经》。吉尼斯世界纪录估计《圣经》已售出超过五十亿册。《古兰经》售出大约八亿册。而《摩门经》售出了约一亿二千万册。我想他们是利用历史记录和各种其他来源来得出这些数字的。
But I couldn't stop there, Angela. I had to know more. What else is there to know? So the top selling books in general are religious texts. But I needed to know, what is just the top selling fiction book? Okay. What is it? It is Don Quixote by Cervantes.
但我不能就此罢休，安吉拉。我必须知道更多。还有什么要知道的？总的来说，最畅销的书籍是宗教文本。但我需要知道，最畅销的小说是什么？好吧。是什么？是塞万提斯的《堂吉诃德》。
And it was published in 1605. It has sold approximately 500 million copies and it has been translated into 145 languages. I had to read Don Quixote, by the way, in my college Spanish class. Oh, well, you are one of the 500 million copies sold. I am. But you know what else is up there, lady? What? Another one you've contributed to.
它于1605年出版。它大约售出了5亿册，已被翻译成145种语言。顺便说一句，我在大学的西班牙语课上不得不读《堂吉诃德》。哦，好吧，你也是售出的这5亿册中的一员。我是。但你知道还有什么名列前茅吗，女士？什么？你也贡献过的一本。
What? Lord of the Rings. Oh! Yeah. I believe it. Yeah. Mm-hmm. People love stories about a journey.
什么？《指环王》。哦！对。我信。对。嗯哼。人们就是喜欢关于旅程的故事。
I guess they do. It's true. Well, I have something to share about this scene. What is it? I was very curious what was in the shooting draft about Michael's book, if there was more. Oh! Because he just pauses and looks off into the distance, right? And then it cuts away and I was like, was there more?
我想是的。确实如此。好吧，关于这个场景我有些话要分享。是什么？我很想知道拍摄剧本里关于迈克尔的书写了什么，是不是还有更多。哦！因为他只是停顿了一下，望向远方，对吧？然后镜头切走了，我想：还有更多吗？
Here's how this moment read in the shooting draft. Michael, you know, is talking into the recorder. Yeah. He says, The Fundamentals of Business by Michael Scott. There is a long beat. Chapter one, the murderer walked into the garden, worriedly, not happily. It was the happiest day of his life. He was going to space.
拍摄剧本里这一幕是这样写的。迈克尔，你知道的，对着录音机说话。对。他说：《迈克尔·斯科特商业基础知识》。有一个很长的节拍。第一章，凶手忧心忡忡地走进了花园，而不是开心地。这是他一生中最开心的一天。他要去太空了。
What? Long beat. Chapter two. That made me laugh. I'm sure they did a whole bunch of alts, right? I bet there was a bunch of candy bags for this one. But that's what was in the shooting draft. Well, now we're going to get into the meat of this episode.
什么？长节拍。第二章。这把我逗笑了。我敢肯定他们做了很多备选方案，对吧？我打赌这一集有很多废弃的糖果袋。但这就是拍摄剧本里的内容。好吧，现在我们要进入这一集的核心内容了。
Michael arrives to work and there's a man sitting on the reception couch waiting to see him. Aaron has allowed this. Michael's not pleased. Michael is so bombed. He's like, you have to protect my creative space. Yeah. I mean, she was like, well, I thought this could be part of your creative space.
迈克尔来到公司，有一个男人坐在前台沙发上等着见他。艾琳放他进来的。迈克尔很不高兴。迈克尔气炸了。他说：你得保护我的创作空间。对。我的意思是，她说：嗯，我觉得这可以是你创作空间的一部分。
And he's like, just push creative space to the afternoon. What did I have? And she's like, free play. He's like, push free play to tomorrow. What is his schedule? I don't know. Well this insurance salesman, Mr. Grady, begins a presentation. Michael's so bored.
而他说：把创作空间推迟到下午吧。我有什么安排？她回答说：自由活动。他说：把自由活动推迟到明天。他的日程表到底是什么样的？我不知道。好吧，这位保险推销员格雷迪先生开始做演示。迈克尔无聊极了。
He has a talking head where he says there's nothing more insulting than listening to a bad salesman is like a good basketball player listening to a bad basketball player. And right after this talking head would have been a pretty important deleted scene for the Pam watercolor fiasco. Oh. It's between Aaron, Stanley, and Meredith. It's in the kitchen and it kind of feels like Aaron is stirring the pot a little like she has some resentment to how long Pam has been on her honeymoon vacation.
他有一个面对镜头的独白，说没有什么比听一个糟糕的推销员说话更侮辱人的了，就像一个优秀的篮球运动员听一个糟糕的篮球运动员说话一样。紧接着这段独白，本该有一个对帕姆水彩画惨剧来说相当重要的被删片段。哦。它发生在艾琳、斯坦利和梅雷迪思之间。是在厨房里，感觉艾琳有点挑拨离间的意思，好像她对帕姆度蜜月去了那么久有些怨气。
But guess who gets her back? You'll never believe it. Let's hear it. Man, doesn't it seem like Jim and Pam have been gone forever? Who gives a crap? Oh, I'm just saying, it's great that she has so much time off. It's unusual. Are you trying to get her in trouble?
但你猜谁帮她说话了？你绝对猜不到。听听看。天呐，不觉得吉姆和帕姆好像已经离开超级久了吗？谁在乎啊？哦，我只是随口说说，她能有这么多假太棒了。这很不寻常。你是在故意给她找麻烦吗？
Not at all. She totally deserves time off for her honeymoon and then I guess for her maternity leave after that. Teacher, teacher, Pam hasn't been in class this week. Backstabbing a pregnant woman. No, I'm just making conversation. We can talk about anything. Meredith, I saw your son's tag on the bridge.
完全没有。她度蜜月理应休假，然后我想接下来就是产假了。老师，老师，帕姆这周没来上课。背后捅刀一个孕妇。不，我只是在闲聊。我们可以聊任何事。梅雷迪思，我看到你儿子在桥上留下的涂鸦了。
Wow, he's so great with a spray can. Look, you're never going to be Pam. We're always going to like her more. Deal with it. Oh my gosh. They kind of both have my back. They do. I mean, Stanley's like your backstabbing a pregnant woman.
哇，他用喷漆罐的水平真高。听着，你永远不会成为帕姆。我们永远会更喜欢她。接受现实吧。哦天哪。他们俩居然都有点维护我。确实。我的意思是，斯坦利说你背后捅刀一个孕妇。
And then Meredith, of course, is like, we're always going to like her more. This would have gone on to another scene where Toby approaches Erin at front reception and says, hey, you really shouldn't be talking about people's time off from work, you know? And she's like, I didn't say anything. I like Pam. And then Toby is like, Erin, it is like really stern with her. And all of those little moments led up to her then trying to prove to everyone she really likes Pam.
然后梅雷迪思当然接着说，我们永远会更喜欢她。接下来还有一个场景，托比在前台接近艾琳并说：嘿，你真的不应该议论别人休假的事，你知道吗？然后她说：我什么都没说。我挺喜欢帕姆的。接着托比说：艾琳，态度对她非常严厉。所有这些小瞬间都导致了她后来试图向每个人证明她真的很喜欢帕姆。
She's going to clean her painting. Wow. Oh my gosh. See, now I did not remember that stuff. I just remembered I obviously was very focused on the destruction part. I didn't get into the motivation part. That's right. I'm still glad it's all gone because it also makes Erin seem petty.
她要清理帕姆的画。哇。哦天哪。看，现在这些内容我全不记得了。我只记得我当时显然非常专注于画作被毁的那部分。我根本没关注动因部分。没错。我还是很高兴这些都被删掉了，因为这也让艾琳看起来显得很小家子气。
And I just, I think it was the right choice. I'm glad you fought for it. Yeah, I agree. It feels a little out of character for Erin to be, you know, stirring the pot. Yeah. Well, after this, there's a scene in accounting that sets up a very funny storyline. There was actually more to it. Oscar and Angela are working.
而且我只是觉得，这是一个正确的选择。我很高兴你为之抗争了。对，我同意。让艾琳去挑拨离间，感觉有点不符合她的人设。对。好吧，这之后，会计部有一个场景，引出了一条非常搞笑的故事线。其实原本还有更多内容。奥斯卡和安吉拉在工作。
Kevin's phone won't stop ringing. They both are looking over at him in Jim's office. He's like eating M&Ms with his feet up on the desk. Angela is staring daggers at him. And Oscar says to her, you could have had Jim's office if you thought of it. And Angela says, I did think of it. I just didn't act on it. And then we cut to Kevin's talking head that explains why he's in Jim's office.
凯文的电话响个不停。他俩都在吉姆的办公室里看着他。他一边吃着M&M巧克力豆，一边把脚翘在桌子上。安吉拉对怒目而视。奥斯卡对她说：如果你想到了，你也能坐进吉姆的办公室。安吉拉说：我想到了。我只是没付诸行动。然后镜头切到凯文的独白，解释他为什么在吉姆的办公室里。
It's because he went in there to fart. Yeah. Which I have to imagine Angela is grateful for. Well, there's that. You know. I know that. During Kevin's talking head at three minutes, five seconds, I caught something, Jenna. What's that?
因为他是进去放屁的。对。我不得不猜想安吉拉对此应该心存感激。好吧，这倒也是。你知道的。我懂的。在3分05秒凯文的独白期间，我捕捉到一个细节，珍娜。是什么？
I got so excited about this moment. I let out a yell and Josh was in the kitchen. I was in our family room and he was like, what's going on? And I'm like, it's Kevin Malone's desk plate, his name desk plate. Yeah. That we talked with Brian about. I saw it too. This would have been the only time anyone would have seen it because it was facing out.
我当时为这个时刻兴奋极了。我大叫了一声，乔什当时在厨房。我在家庭室里，他问：怎么了？我说：是凯文·马龙的桌上名牌，他的名字桌上名牌。对。就是我们跟布莱恩聊过的那个。我也看到了。这将是任何人唯一一次看到它，因为它正面朝外。
Yeah. He put it the right way. He put it the right way and accounting it always just faced himself. I noticed a few other things that Kevin brought to Jim's desk. He brought a Coney Island mug, his M&Ms, of course, and an arena football. I thought that was so interesting. I don't think those things are normally in Jim's office. No, he's clearly moved in.
对。他摆对了方向。他把它摆对了方向，而在会计部它总是只朝着他自己。我还注意到凯文带到吉姆桌上的其他几样东西。他带了一个科尼岛马克杯、他的M&M巧克力豆，当然还有一个竞技室内美式足球。我觉得这太有趣了。这些东西平时不应该在吉姆的办公室里。没错，他显然已经搬进去了。
It's hilarious to me that Michael never said, what are you doing? Why are you in Jim's office? In the shooting draft, it called for a lot of B-roll footage of Kevin in Jim's office. And there was a whole bunch here that they filmed that we didn't see. I'm going to read it to you. He's sitting at his desk. He starts flossing. He yawns, then falls asleep with the floss in his mouth.
迈克尔从来没说过“你在干什么？你为什么在吉姆的办公室里”，这让我觉得太搞笑了。在拍摄剧本中，要求有很多凯文在吉姆办公室里的B滚动画面。这里其实拍了很多我们没看到的画面。我读给你听。他坐在办公桌前。他开始用牙线剔牙。他打了个哈欠，然后嘴里叼着牙线睡着了。
He's also wearing his toupee. Later that day, Kevin is napping with his shirt off scrunched up under his head like a pillow. He has pulled his toupee across his eyes. Hmm. This is like, he lives there now. He does. There was so much B-roll.
他还戴着他的假发。那天晚些时候，凯文光着上身在打盹，衬衫揉成一团垫在头底下当枕头。他把假发拉下来盖在眼睛上。嗯。这简直就是，他现在就住在那里了。他确实住在那里。有太多的B滚动画面了。
Well, he says he likes it better than his own home. He does. Well, Andy and Dwight are watching this meeting go down in the conference room, and they have decided that the insurance salesman is a mobster. Oscar is kind of like, guys, guys, not all Italian Americans are in the mafia. This scene would have continued, but it was deleted where Oscar looks around the office for support. He says, who else is here right now, Angela?
好吧，他说他觉得这里比他自己的家还要好。他确实这么觉得。好吧，安迪和德怀特正在会议室里看着这场会议进行，他们已经认定这个保险推销员是个暴徒。奥斯卡有点像：伙计们，伙计们，并不是所有意大利裔美国人都在黑手党里。这个场景本应继续，但被删掉了：奥斯卡环顾办公室寻找支持。他说：安吉拉，现在这里还有谁？
And Angela says, I didn't see anything. I'm not getting involved. Oscar's like, where's Toby? He's desperately looking for anyone with a voice of reason. Well, it's interesting because when I was trading messages with Brent, he said that this Oscar talking head is the premise of the whole episode, when they were thinking about why this could happen. How could it be that these guys could go so far down this farcical road?
安吉拉说：我什么都没看到。我才不蹚这浑水。奥斯卡说：托比呢？他绝望地寻找任何一个能发出理性声音的人。好吧，有趣的是，当我和布伦特发信息时，他说奥斯卡的这段独白其实就是整集的核心前提，当时他们在思考这怎么可能发生。这些家伙怎么会沿着闹剧的道路走得这么远？
They thought it's because the balance of reason was off because Jim and Pam were gone. Since this is the premise of the whole episode, I thought we should hear it. This is Oscar's talking head. Awesome. Pam and Jim are on their honeymoon, so there's not the usual balance between sane and others. Toby has mentally checked out since June. It's a very dangerous time. The coalition for reason is extremely weak.
他们认为这是因为理性的平衡被打破了，因为吉姆和帕姆不在。既然这是整集的前提，我觉得我们应该听听看。这是奥斯卡的独白。太棒了。帕姆和吉姆去度蜜月了，所以没有了以往理智与其他人之间的平衡。托比自六月份以来就已经精神上躺平了。这是一个非常危险的时期。理性联盟极其薄弱。
It's perfect. I love it. I do want to point out one thing for my background catch people. I'm wearing pants in this episode. Really? You can barely see it, but in this scene where Oscar is pleading to the bullpen to be reasonable, I have my hands in the pockets of my pants. Wow, pants and pockets.
太完美了。我很喜欢。我确实要为我的背景捕捉迷们指出一点。我在这一集里穿了裤子。真的吗？你几乎看不出来，但在奥斯卡恳求办公室其他人保持理智的这个场景里，我的手插在裤子口袋里。哇，裤子和口袋。
Pants and pockets. The coalition of reason. I know, but she doesn't want to get involved. I've seen nothing. I will not get involved. So now we're in the bullpen and everybody is weighing in on whether or not the insurance guy is in the mob. And Ryan is kind of talking about the different mob families.
裤子和口袋。理性联盟。我知道，但她不想卷入其中。我什么都没看见。我绝不参与。所以现在我们在办公区，每个人都在权衡这个保险推销员到底是不是黑手党。瑞安正在谈论不同的黑手党家族。
He's like, it's Goddy. Goddy is the mob family, not Grotty. And they're like, oh, no, no, no, that's perfect. He changed his name. He changed it. And Oscars like, why would he change his name that weakens it? And Dwight argues that it's actually brilliant because R is one of the most menacing sounds. And he has one of my favorite lines.
他说：是戈蒂。戈蒂是黑手党家族，不是格罗蒂。他们说：哦，不，不，不，那太完美了。他改名了。他改了。奥斯卡说：他为什么要改名？这反而减弱了气势。德怀特反驳说这其实非常高明，因为R是极具威胁感的发音之一。他有一句我最喜欢的台词。
That's why they call it murder and not muck duck. It's all too many words and sentences for Michael. He goes in his office. I had gotten a fan question from Andy M and Fort Wayne, Indiana, whoop, whoop, my birthplace, who wanted to know who wrote Dwight's line about muck duck. Was that rain improvising? I laughed so hard every time I watched this scene. Okay.
这就是为什么它被称为谋杀（murder）而不是鸭子嘎嘎叫（muck duck）。这对迈克尔来说有太多的字眼和句子了。他走进了他的办公室。我收到了来自印第安纳州韦恩堡的安迪·M的粉丝提问，哇吼，我的出生地，他想知道德怀特关于鸭子嘎嘎叫的台词是谁写的。那是雷恩即兴发挥的吗？我每次看这个场景都笑得前仰后合。好吧。
It was written and it was intentional and Brent sent in an awesome audio clip about it. Take a listen. Someone asked about the punchline. It's murder not muck duck. That is a wordner joke. Many word nerds may know that in the 1800s, writers had this philosophy that some letters were more powerful than others. The letter R was considered horrifying, which is why Edgar Allen Poe has his raven saying
那是写好的，而且是刻意安排的，布伦特发来了一段超棒的音频剪辑来解释这个。听一听。有人问到了这个笑点。是谋杀，不是鸭子嘎嘎叫。这是一个词源书呆子的笑话。许多词源爱好者可能知道，在19世纪，作家们有一种哲学，认为某些字母比其他字母更有力量。字母R被认为令人毛骨悚然，这就是为什么埃德加·爱伦·坡在他的《乌鸦》中让乌鸦说
nevermore. So when he R's in it, it's so horrifying. Now comedy writers think of the K sound as being a comedy magnifier. That's because it's a plosive K, D and T are plosive letters that apparently add power to words, which is why George Eastman, when he founded a photograph company named it Kodak, a fake word that he felt would be powerful. This is a wordner joke. Or as John Kosinski would say, a Brent joke, as in that sounds like a Brent joke.
“永不复焉”。所以当里面有R的时候，就非常恐怖。现在喜剧作家认为K音是喜剧放大器。那是因为它是爆破音K，D和T是爆破字母，显然能为词语增加力量，这就是为什么乔治·伊士曼在创立一家摄影公司时将其命名为柯达（Kodak），一个他觉得很有力量的虚构词。这是一个词源书呆子的笑话。或者正如约翰·卡辛斯基所说，这是一个布伦特式的笑话，意思是听起来就像布伦特会开的玩笑。
I love that explanation. I did too. Jenna, when I heard Brent's audio clip, it reminded me of this great panel that I saw. It was all of Sid Caesar's writing room, and they were interviewed. It's still on YouTube. And I went back and watched it last night. It's Mel Brooks, Sid Caesar, Carl Reiner, and Neil Simon. And they're talking about what is the funniest number.
我喜欢这个解释。我也喜欢。珍娜，当我听到布伦特的音频剪辑时，让我想起了我看过的一个非常棒的小组讨论。那是希德·凯撒编剧室的全体成员接受采访。它现在还在YouTube上。我昨晚回去看了一遍。那是梅尔·布鲁克斯、希德·凯撒、卡尔·雷纳和尼尔·西蒙。他们在讨论什么数字最搞笑。
And they tell this really great story of how in their writer's room, they spent hours debating what is the funniest number. It's so great. I'm going to put it in our stories when I post for Office Ladies Pod this week because it's just the same thing Brent is talking about. It's like a group of people debating on what sound is funny. What's the answer? What's the funniest number?
他们讲了一个非常精彩的故事，讲他们在编剧室里花了几个小时争论到底哪个数字最搞笑。太精彩了。我会在本周为Office Ladies Pod发帖时把它放到我们的快拍里，因为这和布伦特谈论的是同一回事。就像是一群人在争论到底什么声音才搞笑。答案是什么？最搞笑的数字是什么？
Well, they had a debate about it. There was a story they tell where they thought the number 32, 32 was funny. And then Neil Simon thought 23. But it was like this debate. And the funniest part to me about it is the debate. And then I went on to read online that some comedy writers believe the number 37 is funny. It's like an odd prime number. I think they're all wrong.
嗯，他们为此进行过争论。有个故事说，他们觉得32这个数字，32很好笑。然后尼尔·西蒙觉得是23。但这就像是一场辩论。对我来说，其中最搞笑的部分就是这场辩论。后来我上网看到，一些喜剧编剧认为数字37很好笑。它就像是一个奇素数。我觉得他们都猜错了。
What do you think is a funny number? Nine. Nine times. Nine. Nine. Whenever I'm embellishing a story, I'll be like, I stood there for nine hours, nine. I think nine is funny. I think it's a good punch.
你觉得哪个数字好笑？“九”。九次。“九”。“九”。每当我夸大其词讲故事时，我就会说，我在那儿站了九个小时，九。我觉得九很好笑。我觉得这是一个很好的包袱。
You know what I say? What? Fifty. Oh. Yeah. Like I was there, 50 freaking minutes. I like all the F's. Mmm.
你知道我说什么吗？什么？“五十”。哦。对。就像我在那儿待了整整该死的50分钟。我喜欢里面所有的F开头的词。嗯。
Yeah. It's a really great video though. It just is that moment that you and I love where it's a group of like really funny people brainstorming about the most ridiculous things. That sounds like our writer's room. You know, this whole episode, I couldn't stop thinking about, was there a local mafia in Scranton? Yeah.
对。不过这真是一个非常棒的视频。它刚好捕捉到了你和我都很喜欢的那种时刻，也就是一群超级搞笑的人在头脑风暴，讨论最荒谬的事情。这听起来就像我们的编剧办公室。你知道的，整集节目下来，我一直在想，斯克兰顿有当地的黑手党吗？对。
Like how realistic is this that this guy, because I thought that too. I was like, it's Scranton. I know. So I typed into Google, Scranton, Pennsylvania, mafia, and this is what you texted me. You're like, I did this Google search and I was like, say no more. Wait till tomorrow. Okay. So I'm gonna share with you guys.
这有多现实呢，这家伙……因为我也这么想过。我想，这里可是斯克兰顿。我知道。所以我用谷歌搜索了“宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿黑手党”，这就是你发给我的短信。你说：“我搜了谷歌，当时我就想，别废话了。等着瞧吧。”好吧。所以我要跟你们分享一下。
When I Googled Scranton, Pennsylvania, mafia, this is what came up. There was a Northeastern Pennsylvania mafia. It was known by several different names. The Bufalino crime family, also known as the Pitston crime family, the Scranton Wilkes Berry crime family, the Northeastern Pennsylvania crime family, or the Scranton mafia. Oh. It was an Italian-American mafia crime family based in Northeastern Pennsylvania, primarily in the cities of Scranton, Wilkes Berry, and Pitston.
当我用谷歌搜索“宾夕法尼亚州斯克兰顿黑手党”时，搜出了这些。东北宾夕法尼亚州曾有一个黑手党。它有很多不同的名字。布法利诺犯罪家族，也被称为皮茨顿犯罪家族，斯克兰顿-威尔克斯巴里犯罪家族，东北宾夕法尼亚犯罪家族，或是斯克兰顿黑手党。哦。这是一个美籍意大利人黑手党犯罪家族，总部设在宾夕法尼亚州东北部，主要在斯克兰顿、威尔克斯巴里和皮茨顿这几个城市。
It is believed it's no longer active. But lady, one name kept coming up as I researched the Northeastern Pennsylvania crime families. What name? The Silent or Quiet Dawn, known as Russell Bufalino. I guess he really made his mark in the Italian-American mafia in the mid-20th century. He ruled the Bufalino crime family from 1959 to 1989. He was a cousin of the attorney, William Bufalino, a longtime counsel for Jimmy Hoffa. Huh.
据信它已经不活跃了。但是，女士，在我研究东北宾夕法尼亚犯罪家族时，有一个名字一直被提起。什么名字？被称为“寂静黎明”或“安静黎明”的拉塞尔·布法利诺。我想他在20世纪中叶的美籍意大利人黑手党中确实留下了自己的印记。他在1959年至1989年期间统治了布法利诺犯罪家族。他是律师威廉·布法利诺的表弟，后者是吉米·霍法长期以来的法律顾问。哈。
Stay with me. At his most powerful, Bufalino had operations in Cuba. He was the largest supplier of ammunition to the U.S. government and had close ties with the U.S. Congress. It is rumored that he helped the CIA in their 1961 plot to assassinate Fidel Castro. Oh my gosh. I know. Listen to this.
听我说完。在其势力最鼎盛时期，布法利诺在古巴有业务。他是美国政府最大的弹药供应商，并与美国国会有着紧密的联系。有传言称，他曾协助中情局策划了1961年暗杀菲德尔·卡斯特罗的阴谋。噢天哪。我知道。听着这个。
Apparently, Bufalino introduced Frank Sheeran to the leader of the International Brotherhood of Teamsters, Jimmy Hoffa. Who's Frank Sheeran? Exactly, who was Frank Sheeran? Frank Sheeran is the guy who supposedly years later killed Hoffa. Oh. But for years they worked together. In fact, this is how his job interview went, Frank Sheeran with Jimmy Hoffa.
显然，布法利诺把弗兰克·希兰引荐给了国际卡车司机兄弟会领袖吉米·霍法。谁是弗兰克·希兰？没错，谁是弗兰克·希兰？弗兰克·希兰就是那个据说在多年后杀害了霍法的人。哦。但他们一起共事了很多年。事实上，弗兰克·希兰与吉米·霍法的面试过程是这样的。
It is documented that it was over the telephone. Hoffa was in Detroit, Frank was in Philly. The first words uttered to Frank by Hoffa were, I heard you paint houses. This means, I guess, you whack people. Oh. Because paint is the blood, you know, that splatters on the wall. And then Sheeran replied, yeah, I do my own carpentry too. Which meant, I get rid of the bodies too.
有据可查，那是在电话里进行的。霍法在底特律，弗兰克在费城。霍法对弗兰克说的第一句话是：“我听说你粉刷房子。”我想这意思就是，你把人做掉。哦。因为油漆就是血，你知道的，溅在墙上。然后希兰回答：“没错，我也做我自己的木工活。”这意思是，我也负责处理尸体。
Oh my gosh. I know. And then Frank got the job. And then he painted Jimmy's house. Yes, he did. Because years later, Bufalino started to see Hoffa as a loose cannon and as a liability, right? So he thought he had to be taken out.
噢天哪。我知道。然后弗兰克就得到了这份工作。接着他就粉刷了吉米的房子。没错，他确实这么做了！因为几年后，布法利诺开始把霍法视为一个不可控的危险分子和一个累赘，对吧？所以他认为必须除掉他。
This is the basis of the movie, The Irishman, directed by Martin Scorsese. Wow. Joe Pesci plays Russell Bufalino. Joe Pesci plays the Scranton mobster guy? Yes. The Quiet Dawn. Robert De Niro plays Frank Sheeran, aka The Irishman. And Al Pacino played Jimmy Hoffa.
这就是由马丁·斯科塞斯执导的电影《爱尔兰人》的故事原型。哇。乔·佩西饰演拉塞尔·布法利诺。乔·佩西饰演斯克兰顿的那个黑手党硬汉？是的。“安静黎明”。罗伯特·德尼罗饰演弗兰克·希兰，也就是“爱尔兰人”。而阿尔·帕西诺饰演吉米·霍法。
There's so many books about this crime family. So that is very interesting, but there is one thing that I did not hear in your breakdown. What was that? And that is any insurance selling. Yeah, exactly. Bufalino was not in the insurance business. And it sounds like this crime family had left Scranton by 2009, which is where we are now. Yeah.
关于这个犯罪家族的书籍真是太多了。所以这非常有趣，但有一点我在你的介绍中没有听到。那是什么？那就是任何卖保险的内容。对，没错。布法利诺可不是干保险生意的。听起来这个犯罪家族在2009年（也就是我们现在的设定）之前就已经离开斯克兰顿了。对。
But there was a history. So maybe that is making them nervous, this history. Also Michael probably watches too much TV. Oh, for sure. For sure. Oscar doesn't know what to do because it's spiraling out of control. So he calls Jim for advice and Pam says he shouldn't be calling them unless someone close to them is in danger and hangs up.
但这里面有一段历史。所以也许正是这段历史让他们感到紧张。还有，迈克尔可能电视看太多了。哦，绝对是。肯定的。奥斯卡不知道该怎么办，因为事情已经失控了。所以他打电话向吉姆征求意见，而帕姆说，除非他们身边的人处于危险之中，否则他不应该打电话过来，然后就挂断了。
They're on their honeymoon. We got a fan question from Stephanie Kay in Kansas City, Missouri. Jenna, did you and John basically just get the week off work aside from the phone calls? No, we did not. John and I were in Niagara. Oh. We were filming the made of the missed scenes. Oh my gosh, poor Randy Cordray.
他们正在度蜜月。我们收到了来自密苏里州堪萨斯城斯蒂芬妮·K的一位粉丝提问。珍娜，除了那些电话之外，你和约翰基本上等于放了一周假吗？不，我们没有。我和约翰当时在尼亚加拉。哦。我们在拍摄“情定尼亚加拉”的那些戏份。噢天哪，可怜的兰迪·科德雷。
He must have been juggling so much. He had two shoots, two full shoots happening at the same time in two different states. Yes. So during this week, our script supervisor, Vada, read Jim and Pam's dialogue to the actors on set. And then when John and I got back in town, we came in and we recorded the audio for our side of those conversations with the exception of one scene, which was recorded with John there on set.
他当时一定兼顾了太多事情。他有两个拍摄组，两个全方位的剧组同时在两个不同的州进行拍摄。是的。所以在这周里，我们的剧本总监瓦达在片场把吉姆和帕姆的台词读给演员听。然后等我和约翰回到镇上后，我们就来为那些对话中我们这部分的音频进行配音，只有一个场景除外，那个场景是在约翰在片场的情况下录制的。
I'll tell you when we get to it. Okay. All right. This made me think, Jenna, did you and Lee get any work phone calls on your honeymoon? No. We did not. Right? Josh and I, we didn't either.
等我们讲到那儿时我再告诉你们。好的。好吧。这让我想到了，珍娜，你和李度蜜月时接到过工作电话吗？没有。我们没有。对吧？我和乔希也没有。
Here's how many Jim and Pam got. I broke it down per the shooting draft. Oscar Aaron and Kevin call Pam, Oscar and Michael call Jim. That would be five calls from work, but none of them were actually about real work. In one day. In one day. How many did they get the other days? I don't want to know.
吉姆和帕姆接到了这么多电话。我按照拍摄初稿统计了一下。奥斯卡、阿伦和凯文打电话给帕姆，奥斯卡和迈克尔打电话给吉姆。那将是五个来自工作的电话，但实际上没有一个与真正的工作有关。在一天之内。在一天之内。他们其他几天接了多少个？我可不想知道。
Michael's in his office. He's received a follow-up email from Grady, Dwight and Andy are really in his head now because Michael kind of like, hones in on this one little phrase in the email and takes it to be like a threat. I actually paused and I transcribed the email that Grady sent. You did. Yeah. Because the only part that Michael reads out loud is I feel you will regret and they really
迈克尔在他的办公室里。他收到了格雷迪发来的后续电子邮件，德怀特和安迪现在真的把他的脑子搞糊涂了，因为迈克尔有点像、死盯着邮件里的这小段话，并认为这是一个威胁。我其实暂停了，把格雷迪发的那封邮件逐字抄了下来。你真的抄了。对。因为迈克尔大声读出来的唯一部分是“我觉得你会后悔”，而他们真的
like spiral. But let me just for context read you the whole email and imagine like you're Oscar reading this email. Okay. Okay. You're a voice of reason reading this email. Yes. It says, hi Michael.
情绪失控了。但为了提供上下文，我只把整封邮件读给你们听，想象一下，如果你们是奥斯卡，在读这封邮件。好的。好吧。你是理智的声音，在读这封邮件。是的。上面写着，嗨，迈克尔。
It was a pleasure meeting with you to discuss our company's insurance plans this morning. I'm sorry you felt no need of any insurance coverage at this time and I feel you will regret missing this great opportunity to be in business with Mutual of Harrisburg. Actually you'll reconsider and we can discuss our policies again in the near future, sincerely Angelo Grady. I mean that's boilerplate. That's just a business email. I feel like Michael could have written that same email to someone who didn't want to buy
很高兴今天早上能与您会面，讨论我们公司的保险计划。很遗憾您觉得目前没有任何保险需求的必要，并且我觉得您会错过与哈里斯堡互助公司合作的这个绝佳机会而感到后悔。实际上，您会重新考虑的，我们可以在不久的将来再次讨论我们的保单，诚挚的安杰洛·格雷迪。我的意思是那是套话。那只是一封商务邮件。我觉得迈克尔完全可以把一模一样的邮件写给那些不想买
paper. I feel like you're going to regret missing out on these great prices. Right. But keep us in mind for the future. Maybe I'll check in the next time we have a big sale. Right. It's a theory that Michael uses his computer at all other than to store post-it notes. That's right.
纸张的人。我觉得你会后悔错过这些优惠的价格。对。不过以后有需要请记着我们。也许下次我们大促销时我会来看看。对。这是一个理论，迈克尔用他的电脑除了存便利贴之外别无他用。没错。
Well these guys decide for whatever reason that Michael now needs to meet with Grady but not alone. They'll all go and they're going to let this guy know that Michael cannot be pushed around. He cannot be bullied and he's not going to buy any insurance. Period. Yeah. Period. So he's already not buying any insurance.
好吧，这些人出于某种原因决定，迈克尔现在需要跟格雷迪见上一面，但不能独自前去。他们都要去，并且要让这家伙知道，迈克尔可不是好惹的。他可不是能被恐吓的，而且他绝对不会买任何保险。就这样。对。就这样。所以他本来就已经不打算买任何保险了。
They're going to meet with him to tell him again that he's not buying any insurance. Ridiculous. I would like to point out in this scene Michael has the healthiest plant in the whole entire office. Hmm. Seven minutes, 46 seconds. He has a massive tree. He has a tree in the corner of his office.
他们去见他是为了再次告诉他，他不会买任何保险。荒谬。我想指出的是，在这个场景中，迈克尔拥有整个办公室里长得最健康的植物。嗯。七分四十六秒。他有一棵硕大的树。他办公室的角落里有一棵树。
Is this new? Have we never seen this? What's going on? I don't remember it. I was shocked when I saw it. Where did this tree come from? I don't know. By the way, my peace lily is really doing great and it brings me so much joy.
这是新来的吗？我们以前从没见过吗？怎么回事？我不记得了。我看到的时候惊呆了。这棵树是从哪儿冒出来的？我不知道。顺便说一句，我的白掌长得真的很好，它给我带来了无限的快乐。
I could not be happier. I'm so glad. Truly. I'm so glad. I love plants. I know. Listen lady, I think we should take a break because when we come back the guys are going to have lunch with Grady and there's so much to say.
我简直不能更开心了。我太高兴了。真的。我太高兴了。我喜欢植物。我知道。听着，女士，我觉得我们该休息一下了，因为等我们回来时，这群男士就要和格雷迪共进午餐了，有太多话要说了。
I need a snack first. Maybe I'll have some gaba ghoul or something. All right, let's have some gaba ghoul, we'll be back. All right, this next scene starts out in a parking lot where Michael and Dwight are waiting for Andy who is dressed like a mechanic, a mechanic named Pat with a tire iron which he calls a tire thing. Yeah. And Dwight and Michael are like, why are you dressed like that?
我得先吃点零食。也许我会吃点意式腊肠卷什么的。好吧，我们来吃点意式腊肠卷，一会儿见。好了，接下来这个场景开始于一个停车场，迈克尔和德怀特在那里等安迪，安迪打扮得像个机械修理工，一个叫帕特的修理工，手里还拿着一根轮胎撬棍，他管这叫“轮胎工具”。对。然后德怀特和迈克尔就问，你为什么打扮成这样？
And Andy's like basically the tire iron can be a weapon but he had to dress like a mechanic so it makes sense why he has it. I just want to point out that this man came into our office, sat on reception's couch which is a direct line of vision to Andy's desk. He had to pass by Andy to get into the conference room. So I guess Angelo Grady is not like a super present in the moment, like he makes no connection that he has ever seen Andy before. He completely buys the fact that Andy is a random mechanic who has come to this lunch.
安迪就解释说，基本上轮胎撬棍可以当作武器，但他必须打扮得像个修理工，这样他随身带着它才合情理。我只是想指出，这个人来到我们办公室，坐在前台的沙发上，那个位置正对着安迪的办公桌视线。他必须从安迪身边走过才能进会议室。所以我想安杰洛·格雷迪对当下环境并没有特别敏锐的察觉，他完全没有把眼前的人和之前见过的安迪联系起来。他完全相信了安迪是个偶然路过、来吃这顿午餐的普通修理工。
I know. I just want to say. Yeah. It made me laugh. Here's a little couplet of dialogue that when it was said, I thought, rain improvised that, right? I know what you're going to say because I checked too. Yeah.
我知道。我只想说。对。这把我逗笑了。这里有一小段对白，当时听到的时候，我就想，雷恩是即兴发挥的吧，对吧？我知道你要说什么，因为我也查过。对。
So Michael says, let's go. Come on. Michael says, should I change? And Dwight goes, you're wearing loafers. Michael's like, forget it, forget it. Not in the shooting draft. Not in the script. I've got a location alert for you.
所以迈克尔说：“我们走吧。快点。”迈克尔说：“我要换身衣服吗？”然后德怀特说：“你穿着乐福鞋呢。”迈克尔就说：“算了，算了。”拍摄初稿里可没有这段。剧本里没有。我给你准备了一个外景提示。
Let's hear it. These guys are going to go to the garlic press restaurant. That restaurant is fictional. We made that up. However, when I Googled it, I did find a restaurant in Texas called the garlic press and the menu looked amazing. It reminds me of that restaurant we used to have here called The Stinking Rose. Oh, yes.
说来听听。这群人要去“大蒜压榨机”餐厅。那家餐厅是虚构的。那是我们编造的。不过，当我用谷歌搜索时，我确实在得克萨斯州找到了一家名为“大蒜压榨机”的餐厅，而且菜单看起来棒极了。这让我想起了我们以前在这里开过的那家名叫“发臭的玫瑰”的餐厅。哦，是的。
And it was, everything was garlic on the menu. Every single thing had garlic. I remember that place. Well we shot this at a place called George's Bistro in Valencia. I believe it has since closed, but it was a local Italian favorite and it was located in the Gateway Village Shopping Center, which is where we filmed all the parking lot scenes. So inside the restaurant, they have this scene where Andy sits down and Dwight comes back from the bathroom, you know, because he was scoping the place out, he brings back a roach.
而且它是，菜单上的每一样东西都带大蒜。每一道菜都有大蒜。我还记得那个地方。好吧，我们是在瓦伦西亚一个叫“乔治小酒馆”的地方拍摄的。我想它后来已经关门了，但它曾是一家当地很受欢迎的意大利餐厅，位于门户村购物中心，我们所有的停车场场景都是在那里拍摄的。所以在餐厅里面，他们有这样一个场景：安迪坐下，德怀特从洗手间回来（你知道的，因为他刚才去侦察地形了），他带回了一个蟑螂。
He brings back a roach motel with a roach in it. Yes. And then Andy hits the roach with his tire iron. All right. Brent sent in an audio clip about this one. It's fascinating. Here you go. The creative tension in the shooting of Mafia peaked in that scene in the Italian restaurant.
他带回了一个装着蟑螂的蟑螂屋。是的。然后安迪用他的轮胎撬棍拍打那只蟑螂。好了。布伦特发来了一段关于这事的音频剪辑。太迷人了。给你听听。在拍摄《黑手党》时，意大利餐厅里那场戏中的创作张力达到了顶峰。
When Dwight goes into the bathroom to look for a gun behind the toilet, Allah the godfather he comes back and he says, no gun back there, just this and he tips up a roach motel and a roach falls out on the table. And in the first take of that, Ed Helms spontaneously unscripted smashed the roach with his wrench. After the take, the director Dave Rogers and I ran onto set and we said, oh, that was so funny. Do that again in the next take. And the actress said, oh, no, no, no, no, no, no, we, no, no, Ed will not be doing that
当德怀特走进洗手间去马桶后面找枪时（效仿《教父》），他回来了，他说：“后面没有枪，只有这个。”然后他把一个蟑螂屋翻过来，一只蟑螂掉到了桌上。在那个镜头的第一条实拍中，埃德·赫尔姆斯即兴发挥、没有按剧本演地用他的扳手砸死了那只蟑螂。拍完后，导演戴夫·罗杰斯和我跑到片场说：“哦，太搞笑了。下一个镜头再来一次。”然后女演员说：“哦，不，不，不，不，不，不，我们，不，不，埃德不能再这么做了。”
again. This has become a cartoon. And for eight more takes, Ed never again hit the roach with the wrench. But if you watch the episode, Ed hitting the roach with the wrench is what ends up in the cut. Now what is going on here is the earnest search by talented comedy people to find that balance between what Greg Daniels, the show creator, would call the plausible and the comical. If there's too much plausible, it's not funny.
这都快变成动画片了。在接下来的八个镜头里，埃德再也没有用扳手打过那只蟑螂。但是如果你看这一集，埃德用扳手打蟑螂的画面最终还是留在了剪辑版里。现在这里发生的事情是，有才华的喜剧人在真诚地寻找一种平衡，即剧集创作者格雷格·丹尼尔斯所说的“看似合理”与“滑稽搞笑”之间的平衡。如果太合理了，就不好笑了。
But if there's not enough plausible, it's silly. And the search for that is not easy, nor is it doable even by good people in real time. There's a certain trial and error element to finding comedy tone. So when I heard this clip from Brent, it really made me think about how much trust you put in your director and editor. And when you don't have that trust there, it can make you as an actor not try things. And we did have that trust on our set. And so Ed tried this moment.
但如果不那么合理，又会显得很傻。寻找这种平衡并不容易，优秀的人在实时创作时也无法轻易做到。寻找喜剧基调本身就是一个不断试错的过程。所以当我听到布伦特这段剪辑时，真的让我思考，你对你的导演和剪辑师该有多么信任。而当你缺乏这种信任时，作为演员，你可能就不敢去尝试新东西。我们在片场确实拥有那种信任。所以埃德尝试了这一刻。
And in the moment, it didn't feel right to them. So they were like, we're not going to repeat it. And we would do that all the time. I would try a reaction to something and I would be like, oh my God, no, no, okay, no, no, not doing that again. That was, that was like not the right thing. And then you just kind of, you hope everyone agrees and it doesn't end up in the cut. But then ultimately, sometimes you're wrong.
而在当时，他们觉得这并不对劲。所以他们就想：我们不再重复拍了。我们经常会这样做。我会尝试对某事做出一种反应，然后我会想：天哪，不，不，好了，不，不，再也不这么演了。那感觉、感觉就像是不对的。然后你就会祈祷大家都同意，最后这个镜头不会被剪进正片里。但最终，有时你会弄错。
Like it was the right thing to try. And I just love how our show had all those checks and balances, I guess. Yeah, me too. I thought it made perfect sense. If a cockroach is on a table, all of a sudden you're going to try to whack it or shoo it off or something. Yeah. So that reaction felt very natural to me.
比如尝试这个其实是正确的做法。而且我很喜欢我们的剧集拥有所有这些制衡机制，我想是这样的。是的，我也是。我觉得这完全合乎情理。如果一只蟑螂突然出现在桌子上，你肯定会下意识地去拍打它或者把它赶走什么的。对。所以那种反应对我来说非常自然。
It's probably why he did it in the first take because it was a natural instinct. And I love that audio clip. There's one thing that keeps coming up for me when I hear Brent's voice make a passionate plea about a joke or why something stayed in the episode or the process. He's reminding me a lot of a youth pastor we had at church. He's very passionate. I hear this cadence in his voice that is reminding me of a Sunday worship service a little bit. It's a compliment Brent.
这可能就是他在第一条里这么做的原因，因为那是出于自然的本能。我太喜欢那段音频剪辑了。每当我听到布伦特的声音为某个笑话、或者为什么某个内容能保留在剧集中、或者为制作过程充满激情地进行辩护时，总有一点不断浮现在我脑海里。他让我想起了我们教会里的一个青年牧师。他非常有激情。我在他声音的抑扬顿挫中听到了一点周日崇拜仪式的感觉。这是对你的夸奖，布伦特。
You're very passionate. I'm riveted by your storytelling. While the fellows are at the restaurant, Jim's credit card company calls to verify some charges that seem out of the ordinary. There are charges in Puerto Rico and this has caused a red flag at the credit card company. Yes. So they call Jim's office and Kevin answers the phone. He manages to give Jim's information.
你非常有激情。你的讲述深深吸引了我。正当这帮男士在餐厅里时，吉姆的信用卡公司打电话来核实一些看起来很不寻常的消费。有在波多黎各的消费记录，这在信用卡公司触发了警报。是的。所以他们打通了吉姆办公室的电话，凯文接了电话。他成功地报出了吉姆的信息。
They think he's Jim and they're like, well, you're obviously not in Puerto Rico, so we're going to go ahead and cancel the card. Not just any information. He finds the home address and the last four digits of his social security. Well, lady, at nine minutes and 51 seconds, as Kevin's shuffling through all these papers to give away Jim's information, I noticed something. He has a word search fun book open under all this paperwork. And I thought to myself, is this a character thing or is this a Brian Baumgartner thing?
他们以为他就是吉姆，然后他们就说：“好吧，你显然不在波多黎各，所以我们要把这张卡注销了。”不仅仅是普通信息。他找到了家庭住址和社保号的后四位。好吧，女士，在9分51秒时，当凯文翻找所有这些纸张来泄露吉姆的信息时，我注意到了一件事。在所有这些文件下面，他翻开了一本找字游戏趣味书。当时我就在想，这究竟是角色的设定，还是布赖恩·鲍姆加特纳本人的习惯？
Because I know Stanley always did his crossword puzzles and that tracks for me. But I don't imagine Kevin is sitting around doing word searches. Are you kidding? That is so not Kevin. So I was wondering, you sat with him, Angela. Did Brian do like word searches and his free time in the background? Do you remember? Mostly over in accounting, he was on his computer surfing the internet because you could not
因为我知道斯坦利一直在做填字游戏，这很符合他的作风。但我不认为凯文会闲着没事做字谜搜寻。你在开玩笑吗？那太不像凯文了。所以我在想，你和他坐在一起，安吉拉。布莱恩在后台空闲时会做字谜搜寻吗？你还记得吗？大部分时间他在会计部那边，在电脑上浏览网页，因为你根本
see his screen. He was very lucky. I know. Right? He never got reprimanded for his computer screen. But I imagine over in Jim's glass box, he was visible in so many different ways that maybe he had to do something to pass the time. Very interesting.
看不到他的屏幕。他太幸运了。我懂。对吧？他的电脑屏幕从来没有被警告过。但我想在吉姆的玻璃房里，从很多不同的角度都能看到他，也许他得做点什么来打发时间。非常有意思。
I thought it was fascinating. As I watched the scene, the only thing I could think of was why, Jim? Why would you leave such personal information just laying about your desk? I agree. Why not tidy up a little bit, put that stuff away before you go out of town? Your checkstubs. I do. Is that what you make?
我觉得这太迷人了。当我看着这一幕时，我脑子里唯一浮现的想法就是：为什么，吉姆？你怎么会把这么个人的信息随意丢在桌上？我同意。为什么不稍微收拾一下，在出远门前把那些东西收起来呢？你的工资存根。我是这样的。这就是你的收入吗？
You think that's not going to cause a stir? I agree. Trust no one in that office. Back at the restaurant, when Grotty arrives, he makes some change tables. And I absolutely loved his bit when he says, is this the table you've chosen? It's a half booth, half table. It doesn't know what it is. It made me laugh so hard.
你觉得这不会引起轰动？我同意。在这间办公室里不要相信任何人。回到餐馆，当格罗蒂到达时，他整理了一些桌子。我绝对喜欢他的那个梗，他说，这是你选的桌子吗？这是一半卡座一半桌子。它自己都不知道自己是什么。这让我笑得前仰后合。
I went to the script and that little couple, it wasn't in there. I don't know if it was something on the day or if Mike thought of it, but I love describing that table isn't not knowing what it is. But a waitress is going to come and take their order. Wow. If you do not make Grotty's order exactly how he wants it, he is going to send it back. Michael is fascinated by how Grotty orders. He's taking mental notes.
我查了剧本，那对小两口，剧本里根本没有。我不知道那是现场发挥的还是迈克想出来的，但我很喜欢他形容那张桌子甚至不知道它是什么的样子。不过服务员会来帮他们点餐的。哇。如果你不完全按照格罗蒂的要求做他的菜，他就会退单。迈克尔对格罗蒂点菜的方式着迷了。他在心裡做笔记。
He is. And you know, the whole point of this lunch is that Michael's supposed to seem intimidating. So he's going to try to give a very intimidating lunch order and he's going to order Gabagool. But the waitress doesn't know what he's talking about. He's like, Gabagool. Andy knows. Yeah. Gabagool.
他是。你知道的，这次午餐的重点是迈克尔本该显得很有威慑力。所以他打算点一份非常有威慑力的午餐，他要点加巴古尔（Gabagool）。但服务员根本不知道他在说什么。他说，加巴古尔。安迪知道。对。加巴古尔。
They don't have it. What is Gabagool? I didn't know. I only knew it from one place. The Sopranos. That's right. Yeah. Well, I looked it up and thank you, Esquire.
他们没有这个。什么是加巴古尔？我以前不知道。我只在一个地方听说过。《黑道家族》。没错。是的。嗯，我查了一下，谢谢你，《时尚先生》杂志。
They wrote an article called What the Hell is Gabagool and why does Tony Soprano talk about it all the time? I found an audio clip online where somebody stitched together all the times they say Gabagool on Sopranos. Let's listen to it. I can't feel it. Send me down here for the Gabagool. The Gabagool.
他们写了一篇文章叫《到底什么是加巴古尔，为什么托尼·索普拉诺总是谈论它？》我在网上找到了一段音频剪辑，有人把《黑道家族》里所有提到加巴古尔的地方剪辑在了一起。我们来听听看。我感觉不到。把我送到这儿来就是为了加巴古尔。加巴古尔。
Tony Gabagool, Graham. It's nothing but fat and nitrates. Gabagool. It forward haves salami, Gabagool. Taking the Gabagool and shitting it out of the fridge. Let's get back to that Gabagool. Gabagool. The Gabagool is from a slice of Gabagool.
托尼·加巴古尔，格雷厄姆。这东西除了脂肪和硝酸盐什么都没有。加巴古尔。往前有萨拉米香肠，加巴古尔。把加巴古尔拿出来，然后从冰箱里拉出来。让我们回到那个加巴古尔。加巴古尔。加巴古尔就是一片加巴古尔。
The Gabagool. Okay. Clearly, Michael watches the Sopranos as well. I Googled it. Gabagool is a cured meat. It is known formally as Capicola and it is made from pork shoulder. It's kind of a cross between a sausage and a prosciutto. You would find it on like a charcuterie board.
加巴古尔。好吧。很显然，迈克尔也看《黑道家族》。我谷歌了一下。加巴古尔是一种腌制肉类。它的正式名称是卡比科拉（Capicola），由猪肩肉制成。它有点介于香肠和意大利熏火腿之间。你会在冷盘拼盘里找到它。
Gabagool is kind of like a shorthand for saying Capicola where you just sort of garble it. This is what the article said. That it's like, instead of saying Capicola, you say Gabagool. That's it. It's so interesting because Tony Sopranos' anxiety attacks were triggered by meat. Remember? Yes.
加巴古尔有点像是卡比科拉的简称，你就是随便把它念得含糊不清。这篇文章就是这么说的。就像是不说卡比科拉，而是说加巴古尔。就是这样。这太有趣了，因为托尼·索普拉诺的焦虑症是由肉类引发的。记得吗？是的。
Yeah. What isn't in that audio clip that we played were all of these additional scenes of him just standing in the fridge eating Gabagool. He would often get up in the middle of the night and eat it. And then he would have an anxiety attack. Well, ultimately, Michael can't order Gabagool because they don't have it. So instead, he says he'll order spaghetti with the side salad. If the salad is on top, he'll send it back.
对。我们刚才播放的那段音频剪辑里没有包含的是，他站在冰箱里吃加巴古尔的各种额外镜头。他经常在半夜醒来吃这个。然后他就会焦虑发作。好吧，最终，迈克尔点不了加巴古尔，因为他们没有。所以相反，他说他要点意大利面配一份配菜沙拉。如果沙拉在上面，他就把菜退掉。
Yeah. If the salad is on top of his spaghetti. Yeah. And the shooting draft the scene continues. Andy is also going to order. Here's what Andy orders. He would like a ham sandwich on white bread with mayonnaise and some Lowry's salt. Oh.
对。如果沙拉在意大利面上方的话。是的。在拍摄初稿中，这一幕还在继续。安迪也要点餐。安迪点的是这些：他想要一份夹在白面包里的火腿三明治，加蛋黄酱和一些劳瑞斯（Lawry's）盐。哦。
Lowry's seasoning salt on top of his ham sandwich. I love a Lowry's seasoning salt on top of some salmon before you grill it. I mean, you can really put it on anything. You really can. I wouldn't think to put it on ham. Oh, why not? I think it would be great. I mean, ham's already a little salty, but I really think you can put it on almost anything.
他的火腿三明治上面撒了劳瑞斯调味盐。我喜欢在烤三文鱼之前在上面撒一些劳瑞斯调味盐。我的意思是，你真的可以把它加到任何东西上。确实可以。我可不会想到把它加到火腿上。哦，为什么不呢？我觉得会很棒。我是说，火腿本来就有点咸，但我真的觉得你几乎可以把它加到任何东西上。
I don't disagree. Oh, I just saw this fan question from Kimberly W. in Fort Worth, Texas. It's going back to Gabba Gull. She would like you to know that black cat pizza in Fort Worth, Texas has a special order, Gabba Gull pizza. And I looked it up. What's on it? It's their take on a meatlover's pizza and it has capicola, which is Gabba Gull, pepperoni,
我不反对。哦，我刚看到德克萨斯州沃斯堡的金伯利·W提出的一个粉丝问题。这又要回到加巴古尔了。她希望你知道，德克萨斯州沃斯堡的黑猫比萨店有一款特色点单——加巴古尔比萨。我查了一下。上面有什么？这是他们对肉食爱好者比萨的诠释，里面有卡比科拉，也就是加巴古尔、意式辣香肠，
goprasada, spicy Italian sausage, a bunch of peppers, mozzarella and provolone on a marinara. It's 11.15 here and I'm now hungry. Oh, I know. I wish. Will you also love a charcuterie board? I do. I mean, it's, you know, it goes with the cheese that you love.
辣味意大利香肠（goprasada）、辛辣意式香肠、各种辣椒、马苏里拉奶酪和波萝伏洛奶酪，搭配番茄玛丽娜拉酱。这里现在是11点15分，我已经饿了。哦，我懂。我希望。你也喜欢冷盘拼盘吗？我喜欢。我的意思是，你知道的，它和你喜欢的奶酪很搭。
I love it. Oh, I read today's National Cheese Day. What? Yeah. It is? I know. I'm going to put that on my calendar for next year because I want to be the friend that sends you cheese on National Cheese Day.
我喜欢。哦，我读到今天是全国奶酪日。什么？对。是吗？我知道了。我要把它记在明年的日历上，因为我想成为那个在全国奶酪日给你寄奶酪的朋友。
That is some serious BFF territory. I love you for it. Oh, wait. We got another fan question from Izzy T and Pittsburgh, Pennsylvania, who wants to know who played the waitress. I think she was very funny. I agree with you, Izzy. She was played by Deborah Puete.
这绝对是铁磁（BFF）级别的范畴了。我爱你。哦，等等。我们收到了来自宾夕法尼亚州匹兹堡的伊兹·T的另一个粉丝问题，她想知道扮演服务员的是谁。我觉得她非常搞笑。我同意你的看法，伊兹。她由黛博拉·普埃特（Deborah Puete）饰演。
I hope I'm saying your last name right, Deborah. She has been on, oh my gosh, Parks and Recreation, Grey's Anatomy, Strong Medicine, and she's also a theater producer. She won a Drama Desk Award in 2011 for producing the play Four Places. Awesome. Well, we have another guest star alert because a woman and her child are going to approach Andy because he's dressed like a mechanic. Her car won't start and she needs his help.
希望我没有念错你的姓，黛博拉。她参演过，哦天哪，《公园与游憩》、《实习医生格蕾》、《强力药剂》，她还是一位戏剧制作人。她因制作戏剧《四个地方》而获得2011年戏剧桌奖。太棒了。好吧，我们又迎来了客串明星警报，因为一个女人和她的孩子要走近安迪，因为他穿得像个机械师。她的车发动不着了，需要他的帮助。
Yes. The son was played by Ray Latt, the son was played by Tucker Elbrizzi, and, you know, she's going to regret asking for Andy's help because he kind of blows up her car. Oh my gosh, he clearly knows nothing about cars. He even says, you know what, I have a great guy that can help you. Andy told us that to make the battery spark and blow up in the scene was another special effect engineered by Mike Thompson. He used squibs, which are electronically ignited devices that spark, and they also used an electronically
是的。儿子由雷·拉特饰演，另一个版本中儿子由塔克·埃尔布里齐（Tucker Elbrizzi）饰演，你知道的，她会后悔向安迪寻求帮助的，因为他直接把她的车给炸了。哦天哪，他显然对汽车一无所知。他甚至说，你知道吗，我有个很棒的修车师傅可以帮到你。安迪告诉我们，让电池在这一幕中产生火花并爆炸是迈克·汤普森设计的又一个特效。他使用了爆破片，也就是通过电子点火会产生火花的装置，他们还使用了电子
triggered smoke generator, and he also sent us a video of them testing the effect. You got to put it in stories. I love how they have to test this stuff. You're not just going to hand-ed some electric things and make it blow up. Somebody has to test that first. But just in case you find yourself with a dead battery, I am going to tell you how to jumpstart a car. You know, I feel like our rabies information really helped some people, and so I'd like
触发的烟雾发生器，他还给我们发了一段他们测试特效的视频。你必须把它发到故事（Stories）里。我喜欢他们必须测试这些东西的方式。你不能只是把一些带电的东西交到别人手里然后让它爆炸。总得有人先测试一下。但以防万一你的车电瓶也没电了，我要告诉你如何给汽车搭电。你知道的，我觉得我们的狂犬病知识确实帮助了一些人，所以我很想
to offer this for you all. Okay. So you're going to need a car with a battery that's working and then you'll have your dead battery car. Before you start, make sure both cars are off. Then you take the red clamp, which is positive, and you clamp it on the dead battery. Start with dead battery first. That's right.
把这个分享给大家。好的。所以你需要一辆电瓶正常的车，然后是你的电瓶没电的车。在开始之前，确保两辆车都是熄火状态。然后你拿红色的夹子，也就是正极，把它夹在没电的电瓶上。先从没电的电瓶开始。没毛病。
Then attach the red clamp to the positive terminal of the working battery. Then stay where you are. Clamp the negative, which is the black clamp, to the working battery. And then complete the circle by clamping the negative to not the battery, but to any unpainted metal surface of the dead car. You don't go battery, battery, battery, battery. Then start the working car. Then start the dead car.
然后将红色的夹子连接到有电电瓶的正极接线柱上。然后呆在原地不动。将负极，也就是黑色的夹子，夹到有电的电瓶上。然后通过将负极夹在——不是电瓶上，而是夹在没电的车上任何没有漆的金属表面上，来闭合回路。你不能按照电瓶、电瓶、电瓶、电瓶这样夹。然后启动有电的车。然后启动没电的车。
Right. Then remove the cables in the reverse order that you attached them, and you have to keep the previously dead car running for several minutes, or you can drive around for like 15 minutes, and then your battery will be recharged. So positive, positive, negative, negative not to battery, turn on cars. One of my friends in my early 20s out here, you know, when you move out here and you're just at the very beginning trying to start out. This car was a bit of a clunker, and there were a few times we had to do that after like
对。然后按照你连接它们的相反顺序取下电缆，你必须让刚才没电的车保持运转几分钟，或者你可以开着车转大约15分钟，然后你的电瓶就会充满电了。所以顺序是正极、正极、负极、负极不要夹在电瓶上，然后发动汽车。我在20出头刚搬到这里的时候，你知道的，当你刚搬到这里，正处在生活刚起步的阶段。这辆车有点破旧，有好几次我们都不得不这么做，比如在
performing at comedy clubs, we'd be like, does anyone have jumper cables? Oh, yeah, me too. I found out why Andy had the problems he had. If you connect the negative first, there's a chance that a little short circuit and the battery will explode. Oh, yeesh. Also this website just wants you to know, never try to jump a frozen battery and don't try to jump a broken or leaky battery.
喜剧俱乐部表演完之后，我们会问：有人有搭火线吗？哦，对，我也是。我找到了安迪遇到那些问题的原因。如果你先连接负极，很有可能会造成一个小短路，然后电池就会爆炸。哦，天哪。这个网站还想让你知道，永远不要试图给结冰的电池搭电，也不要试图给损坏或漏液的电池搭电。
Good to know, guys. Good to know. Our final moment here with Mr. Grady at the restaurant is a real power struggle between Dwight and Andy. Dwight says don't sign the letter of intent. Andy really wants him to sign it so they can be done with all this. Michael signs the paper, and Dwight is really disappointed. I just want to point out, I love how they all ordered dessert at a lunch that they didn't
记住了，伙计们。记住了。我们在这里与格雷迪先生在餐馆里的最后一个镜头是德怀特和安迪之间真正的权力斗争。德怀特说不要签署意向书。安迪真的很想让他签字，这样他们就可以摆脱这一切了。迈克尔在文件上签了字，德怀特非常失望。我只想指出，我喜欢他们在一场甚至都不想去的午餐上点甜点的样子。
want to go to. I know. I mean, this was a three-course meal. I looked in the shooting draft to see if there was anything about what really was in this insurance policy, like what did it cover? The shooting draft did not disappoint. Mr. Grady says to Michael, so from getting to know you a little, I think this policy is the right size for you.
我知道。我的意思是，这是一顿三道菜的大餐。我在拍摄初稿里找过，看看里面有没有关于这份保险政策到底是什么内容、它涵盖了什么的具体信息。拍摄初稿没有让人失望。格雷迪先生对迈克尔说，所以通过对你的一些了解，我认为这份保单对你来说尺寸正合适。
It will provide enough for your mother to eat at Red Lobster for the rest of her days. Endow a scholarship in your name at Hamburger University, and preserve your brain and genitals in a cryogenic lab. Okay, well Michael says, listen, it's only the same as the cost of one cup of coffee per hour. To preserve your brain and genitals? What a deal. Well, I looked it up, and the average cost of a hot black coffee in the United States
它将为你的母亲提供足够的资金，让她在余生中都能在红龙虾（Red Lobster）餐厅吃饭。以你的名字在汉堡大学设立奖学金，并将你的大脑和生殖器保存在低温实验室里。好吧，迈克尔说，听着，这笔费用只相当于每小时一杯咖啡的钱。为了保存你的大脑和生殖器？这买卖太划算了。好吧，我查了一下，在美国，一杯热黑咖啡的平均价格
is $2.70. So that means Michael's policy costs $23,587 a year. Wow. I thought that was a lot. I thought $2.70 for a cup of coffee was a lot, but it is not the most expensive cup of coffee in the world, according to the Global Coffee Report, which ranks 104 countries. In South Korea, the average cost of just a black coffee is $7.77. Whoa.
是2.70美元。所以这意味着迈克尔的保单每年要花费23,587美元。哇。我觉得这很多。我觉得一杯咖啡2.70美元已经很多了，但根据对104个国家进行排名的全球咖啡报告显示，这并不是世界上最贵的咖啡。在韩国，仅一杯黑咖啡的平均价格就高达7.77美元。哇。
I know. The least expensive cup of coffee is in Iran, where you can get a cup of coffee for just $0.49. Hmm. Well, you can certainly see why Michael's in a bit of a jam financially, because he's just signed a policy he can't afford. At all. At all.
我知道。最便宜的一杯咖啡在伊朗，你在那里只需花0.49美元就能买到一杯咖啡。嗯。好吧，你当然可以看出为什么迈克尔在经济上陷入了困境，因为他刚刚签署了一份他根本负担不起的保单。完全负担不起。根本负担不起。
And I was like, wait, as they're walking to the car, it's like, what happened there? And Michael's like, I had to make a snap decision. And this line that Dwight says, do you know what a snap decision means? And then he snaps. I was like, that's rain improvising. It has to be. So I went to the shooting draft, and it's not in the shooting draft. This is what was scripted.
然后我想，等等，当他们走向汽车时，就像是，那儿到底发生了什么？迈克尔说：我必须做出迅速的决定。德怀特说的这句台词：你知道迅速决定是什么意思吗？然后他打了个响指。我想，那是雷（雷·罗马诺）即兴发挥的。肯定是。所以我去查了拍摄初稿，拍摄初稿里根本没有。剧本是这样写的：
Michael says, I had to make a snap decision, Dwight. Dwight says, no, you didn't. You were sitting there for an hour. Please tell me you only agreed to term life insurance. Michael holds up a pamphlet, Dwight snatches it. He looks at it and says, an annuity, no. And then Andy excitedly squeaks. And Michael goes, what?
迈克尔说：德怀特，我必须做出迅速的决定。德怀特说：不，你没有。你在那儿坐了一个小时。请告诉我你只同意购买定期寿险。迈克尔举起一本小册子，德怀特一把抢了过来。他看了一眼说：年金（Annuity），没有吧。然后安迪兴奋地发出尖叫。迈克尔说：什么？
Andy says, nothing. And then Andy turns to camera and has this talking head on the fly. He annuity was doing a, and then he smiles and goes, the mood was wrong. I don't get the joke. He annuity was doing, like signing up for this insurance. Oh, he annuity. He's making a pun. He annuit he.
安迪说：没什么。然后安迪转向镜头，现场现编了一段访谈。他年金（He annuity）在做……然后他笑着说：气氛不对。我不懂这个笑话。他年金在做，就像注册买这个保险一样。哦，他年金。他在玩双关语。他年金他（He annuit he）。
Yeah, but he's doing it like in an accent, like he annuity was doing, eh? Oh my God. That's like a hardcore dad pun right there. I know. And then I guess it's like crickets. And he goes, ah, the mood was wrong. Wow. That's what was in the script.
对，但他说话带点口音，就像“他年金在做（he annuity was doing），啊？”天哪。这绝对是一个硬核的老爸冷笑话。我知道。然后我猜现场一片沉寂，鸦雀无声。他说：啊，气氛不对。哇。剧本里就是这样的。
I think he annuity, what he was doing is a Brent joke. For sure. That's a word nerd pun joke. For sure. For sure. Back in the office, Michael decides he needs some advice from Jim. And so he is the latest person to call him on his honeymoon. They're on a catamaran.
我觉得“他年金在做（he annuity, what he was doing）”是个布伦特（大卫·布伦特）式的笑话。肯定的。那是书呆子式的双关笑话。肯定的。肯定的。回到办公室，迈克尔决定向吉姆征求一些建议。于是他是最新一个在吉姆度蜜月期间给他打电话的人。他们在一艘双体船上。
Yes. I'm very surprised Jim answered, to be honest. It's a very funny bit. This is the scene where John was actually on the other line and the two of these guys, they started improvising. They went off script. This whole thing with the crackle and you'll be saved. And then Michael is like, what are you?
是的。老实说，我很惊讶吉姆接了电话。这是一个非常搞笑的桥段。这就是约翰当时在电话另一头的那场戏，这两个家伙开始即兴发挥。他们脱离了剧本。关于噼里啪啦然后你就会得救的整段内容。然后迈克尔说：你是什么人？
I can't. And he's like, and you'll be saved. They came up with that on the day. So fun. It shows the value of having the actor there live, especially on a show like ours that, you know, encouraged improvisation. And especially between John and Steve, who were so good at this Jim Michael dynamic. Yes.
我不行。然后他说：然后你就会得救。那是他们当天现场想出来的。太有趣了。这展现了演员在现场的价值，特别是对于像我们这样鼓励即兴发挥的剧来说。尤其是约翰和史蒂夫之间，他们太擅长这种吉姆和迈克尔的动态关系了。是的。
Well, Dwight over here is Michael talking to Oscar. He's clearly stressing out. And Dwight says, we've got to fix this. Michael is broke and living in fear with no friends at a dead end job. Yeah. I know. And Andy's kind of like, well, I mean, some of those things were true before today. And Dwight's like, not the fear part.
好吧，德怀特看到迈克尔在和奥斯卡说话。他显然压力很大。德怀特说：我们得解决这个问题。迈克尔破产了，生活在恐惧中，在一份没有前途的工作中没有朋友。对。我知道。安迪有点像是，嗯，我是说，其中有些情况在今天之前就已经存在了。德怀特说：恐惧的那部分可没有。
So they come up with this plan that they're going to convince Michael that Mr. Grady is not in the mafia, even though in truth, Andy and Dwight still think he is, but they go in and Andy's like, I have a friend who's a fed. This guy checks out. Dwight says he has a friend on the police force that also clears Grady's name and also cleared the fed just to make sure that he wasn't on the take. That's right. Oh my gosh, Steve's performance.
于是他们想出了一个计划，要让迈克尔相信格雷迪先生不是黑手党，尽管事实上安迪和德怀特仍然认为他是，但他们走进去，安迪说：我有个联邦调查局的朋友。这家伙经得起查。德怀特说他有一个在警察局的朋友也洗清了格雷迪的名字，为了确保他没有收受贿赂，还顺便查了一下那个联邦调查局的人。没错。哦天哪，史蒂夫的表演。
That moment when he, as Michael thinks he's been lied to, the look that came over his face, Jenna, I was like, oh, Steve is so good. I love every time Steve realizes something as Michael. Yes. So Michael says, if there's one thing I hate more than the mafia, it's a liar, right? He's going to call up this guy. Oh, and he gets on the phone and he lays into him and he cancels his policy. Everybody is so happy.
当他作为迈克尔意识到自己被骗了的那一刻，他脸上的表情，珍娜，我想，哦，史蒂夫太棒了。我喜欢史蒂夫作为迈克尔每次恍然大悟的时刻。是的。所以迈克尔说：如果说我有什么比恨黑手党更恨的东西，那就是骗子，对吧？他要打电话给这家伙。哦，他接起电话，狠狠地数落了对方一番，然后取消了他的保单。所有人都太高兴了。
And then Dwight and Andy are like, yeah, they tell him what they did. He just stood up to a mobster. And Michael's like, oh God, oh God, I should be mad at you guys. Yeah. And how he just feels like a badass. Well Brent sent in a final audio clip where he explains why he thinks this ending works so well and why he believes it endures. I think the Office Episode Mafia is an original contribution to the history of comedy because
然后德怀特和安迪就像是，耶，他们告诉迈克尔他们做了什么。他刚刚顶撞了一个黑手党。迈克尔就觉得，哦天哪，哦天哪，我真不该生你们的气。是的。以及他是如何觉得自己像个硬汉的。好吧，布伦特发来了一段最后的音频剪辑，他在其中解释了他为什么认为这个结局效果这么好，以及为什么他相信它能经久不衰。我认为《办公室》的“黑手党”这一集对喜剧史做出了独创性的贡献，因为
there is a real story and there's a fake story. And all of the stakes for the characters happen in the fake story. But the actors grounded and played so real that we actually feel stakes for them and we actually feel their emotional resolution at the end. It also has an incredibly original ending where Dwight and Andy fake Michael into believing the truth. And this quote false understanding of reality is what allows Michael to solve his problems in the fake story.
有一个真实的故事，还有一个虚构的故事。角色们所经历的所有险境都发生在虚构的故事中。但演员们的表演非常扎实、真实，以至于我们真的为他们感到担忧，并在最后感受到了他们的情感释怀。它还有一个极具原创性的结局，德怀特和安迪让迈克尔假装相信了真相。正是这种对现实的虚假理解，让迈克尔在虚构的故事中解决了他的问题。
It's highly original. And I think those scenes of Andy, Dwight and Michael in Michael's office will stand the test of time with comedy nerds forever. Well it stood the test of time for me. I loved the complexity of it. For sure. And you know, a little piece of Mr. Grady is going to stay with Michael now. Forever.
这非常有创意。而且我认为安迪、德怀特和迈克尔在迈克尔办公室里的那些场景，在喜剧迷心中将永远经得起时间的考验。这对我来说经受住了时间的考验。我喜欢它的复杂性。确实如此。而且你知道，格雷迪先生的一小部分现在将留在迈克尔身边。永远。
Oh yeah. I mean, look at how he orders coffee at the end. Aaron, I want coffee. Not from the kitchen. The stop and shop. If it's not the stop and shop, I send it back. Large, if it's a medium, I send it back. If it's an extra large, I send it back.
哦，是的。我是说，看看他在最后是怎么点咖啡的。艾伦，我要咖啡。不要厨房里的。要Stop and Shop超市的。如果不是Stop and Shop的，我就退回。大杯的，如果是中杯的，我就退回。如果是超大杯的，我就退回。
So there is part of Michael and Mr. Grady that are always going to be together. I also want to point out that at 20 minutes and 49 seconds, very briefly over Michael's shoulder as he's bragging to the bullpen about standing up to this mobster, you can see that there is a replacement painting on the wall where Pam's watercolor would have been. It says being cleaned and it has stars and smiley faces all around it. This is something that Aaron put up on the wall. Now in the next episode, that's going to be replaced with something else, but we'll get to it.
所以迈克尔和格雷迪先生有一部分将永远在一起。我还想指出，在20分钟49秒的时候，当迈克尔向办公区吹嘘自己如何对抗这个黑帮时，从迈克尔的肩膀上方极快地闪过，你可以看到墙上有一幅替代画，原本应该是帕姆的水彩画的地方。上面写着“正在清洗”，周围都是星星和笑脸。这是艾伦挂在墙上的东西。现在在下一集里，它将被别的东西取代，但我们到时候再说。
Well, Sam was motioning to me. Sam, what do you got? What'd we miss? Your Angela's digital clutter sting is ready. You made one? Yeah, I made it during this episode. You did? No way.
嗯，萨姆在向我打手势。萨姆，你有什么？我们漏掉了什么？你的安吉拉数字杂乱提示音准备好了。你做一个？对啊，我在这集播放时做的。真的吗？不会吧。
Let's hear it. Here we go. Angela's digital clutter. It could sound like The Matrix if I did it right. It does. It does, it sounds like Neo getting a message. Oh, Sam, I love it so much. Thank you.
我们听听看。开始吧。安吉拉的数字杂乱。如果我做得对的话，听起来可能像《黑客帝国》。确实像。确实，听起来像尼奥收到一条信息。哦，萨姆，我太喜欢了。谢谢你。
All right, Sam, you need to save that because next week, fast fact number three is going to be Angela's digital clutter. You guys, there literally might be nothing but okay. That's what's so riveting about it. What's it going to be? We don't know. Will it pay off? Will it not?
好的，萨姆，你需要保存好那个，因为下周，第三个快速冷知识将是安吉拉的数字杂乱。伙计们，字面意思可能什么都没有，但好吧。这就是它的吸引人之处。会是什么呢？我们不知道。会有回报吗？会没有吗？
We'll have to wait until next week when we break down the Lover. And also, we want to say thank you to Brent Forrester for sending in those audio clips. Check out his TV comedy course. You can go to BrentForrester.com. See you guys next week. We hope you have a great day. Thank you for listening to Office Ladies. Office Ladies is produced by Earwolf, Jenna Fisher, and Angela Kinsey.
我们得等到下周我们解析《情人》那一集。另外，我们要感谢布伦特·福雷斯特发来那些音频剪辑。去看看他的电视剧喜剧课程吧。你可以访问BrentForrester.com。大家下周见。希望你们度过美好的一天。感谢收听《办公室女士》。《办公室女士》由Earwolf、珍娜·费舍尔和安吉拉·金斯利制作。
Our show is executive produced by Cody Fisher. Our producer is Cassie Jerkins, our sound engineer is Sam Kieffer, and our associate producer is Ainsley Bubicoe. Our theme song is Rubber Tree by Creed Bratton. For ad-free versions of Office Ladies, go to StitcherPremium.com. For a free one-month trial at Stitcher Premium, use code, Office. There aren't comments yet for this episode. Click on any sentence in the transcript to leave a comment.
我们的节目的执行制片人是科迪·费舍尔。我们的制作人是卡西·杰金斯，我们的音响工程师是萨姆·基弗，我们的副制作人是艾恩斯利·布比科。我们的主题曲是克里德·布拉顿的《Rubber Tree》。要收听无广告版的《Office Ladies》，请访问StitcherPremium.com。在Stitcher Premium免费试用一个月，请使用优惠码：Office。本集尚无评论。点击文稿中的任意句子即可发表评论。